another day another failed attempt at
death if scp-682 had anything even
resembling a sense of humor you might
ask for it to be printed on a
motivational poster and stuck to the
side of his containment chamber where he
eternally melts and regrows at the mercy
of high concentration acid they just
cross-tested him with Abel again unlike
some of the others he'd been forced to
face that tattooed swordsman seemingly
wasn't intelligent enough to fear he'd
always come back just as stupid and
violent this encounter had left the hard
to destroy reptile at 30 percent of his
previous body mass bloody and bashed
he'd survived the encounter he always
survived they brought what was left of
him back to his cell in a forklift a
blasted forklift how could it even be
more humiliating as his eyes started to
grow back in his head he could swear he
even saw one of the technician is
laughing at him his name tag read agent
Nigel Kelly noted 682 would specifically
hunt down and kill him the next time he
breached of course every single day he
plotted revenge against the human race
along with everything else but the sum
they owed in pain blood and despair
could never be repaid in full after all
every single one of them except Dr
bright could only really die once they'd
brought 682 to the precipice a thousand
times only for his own body to cheat him
and deprive him of the sweet release of
death and if the foundation had their
way it would be done a thousand times
more and they wouldn't even stop there
682 couldn't even imagine the number of
containment breaches it would take to
deal a blow even comparable to the one
he had faced all he could do was dream
dream of a reckoning that would turn the
labels something that would plunge
Humanity into the state of constant pain
and Terror that had been all he'd ever
known since these fumbling sadists and
white coats had locked him up here what
a beautiful day that would be little did
scp-682 know that very day was about to
break miles and miles away from the
facility where scp-682 was kept after
all orders from the o5 council have hard
mandates on the minimum distances
between people and a site holding a
monster as volatile as 682 parents
watched their children laughing and
frolicking in an idyllic playground some
squealed with Glee as they descended the
slide some of the more ambitious Little
Tikes tried to go over the bar on the
swings others waited in line for some
delicious soft serve at a parked ice
cream truck one mother brought an ice
cream cone and walked over to a nearby
bench where she began to enjoy her
delicious Frozen treat was a remarkably
hot day out and a little ice cream was
the perfect addition to her relaxation
while her kids were occupied you could
see the distant air wobbling in the heat
already her ice cream was starting to
melt white rivulets dribbling down the
sides of the cone and onto her hands
suddenly almost imperceptibly the
quality of the light shifted the kind of
thing you'd dismiss as a trick of the
eyes and forget just as quickly were it
not for the catastrophic effects that
were about to unfold as the woman leaned
forward to liquor melting ice cream
something dripped onto her skirt but as
she looked down she slowly realized that
what dripped onto her wasn't the Pure
White of her ice cream it was the same
exact tone as her skin she felt a
terrible burning sensation all through
her body the most horrible debilitating
pain she'd ever experienced like every
cell in her body was screaming and
trying to make a break for it she turned
to the other parents sitting near the
playground they were screaming too each
collapsed to the ground with agonizing
slowness different parts of their body
falling at different speeds as they
transition through states of matter when
they hit the ground they were taking on
a liquid state screaming worthless
boneless blobs the woman even saw her
own arm wilting like a Time Lapse video
of a Dying flower she dripped and
sluiced through the cracks in the bench
until nothing recognizably human was
left only a soggy ice cream cone sitting
uneaten in an instant billions of
Screams rang out over planet Earth they
had broken things would never ever be
the same again as almost half of
humanity instantaneously took on a
liquid state needless to say with the
most dangerous and far-reaching
anomalous incident in human history
suddenly breaking out without any kind
of warning the SCP Foundation was
incredibly busy this would take some
unprecedented action the members of the
o5 council who weren't melted during the
initial blast convened over secure video
link while sequestering themselves
underground in what amounted to multiple
human lifetimes of some of the most high
pressure choices imaginable they made
the most difficult decision since the
very beginning of the SCP Foundation in
the service of all mankind they would
now break the Masquerade the SCP
Foundation would at long last step out
of the Shadows to save the rest of
humanity from the tyranny of the light
broadcasts went out all over the globe
every TV screen every live stream every
radio broadcast was commandeered they
gave instructions based on the scattered
Intel they had for some reason the sun
had turned against them exposure would
lead need any biological creatures
melting away into sentient piles of
flesh-colored sludge people would remain
indoors and away from any light sources
all windows must remain covered travel
only at night and even then heavily
covered with protective gear there can
only be one objective for whoever is
left make your way to the nearest SCP
Foundation containment facility and seek
Refuge inside if anyone could figure out
the answer to this terrifying
existential riddle it would be the SCP
Foundation anyone who is exposed should
be considered lost while as always the
SCP Foundation did all they could to
project a sense of control over the
situation on the inside it was
pandemonium somehow despite everything
this event had taken all of them by
surprise how could anyone have predicted
that the Cradle of our Solar System's
delicate living balance would suddenly
become a meat grinder a huge number of
foundation operatives were wiped out in
the initial exposure Global
Communication infrastructure had been
devastated it was pure chaos and to
scp-682 as another evil tactician once
put it chaos was a ladder from the
inside of his acid tank 6av2 could sense
the fear and pain suddenly exuding from
his surrounding environment it was
greater than ever before what was
happening out there this was no average
Containment Breach something was really
really happening out there 682 began to
adapt and finally attune its hearing
until it could pick up the chatter from
outside maybe we can convert some of the
d-class barracks into serviceable
bunkers for the refugees it's not like
we're prepared for this kind of capacity
oh God oh God we've lost sight seven
sight 10 site 23 site 40 site 52 ah
death toll looks to be in the billions
well we don't know if they're dead
technically but there sure as hell not
human anymore well this is the big one
this is it XK class even 2 000 is
unaccounted for is all that crazy that
they think we're fighting the freaking
Sun needless to say 682's curiosity was
piqued anything that could light a fire
under the foundation like this was
something he could enjoy and with his
impressively strategic intellect he
intuited that a time of great Strife for
the foundation would be the perfect time
to breach containment because whenever
there's violence fear and Chaos on a
mass scale
scp-682 will be there causing it 682
began adapting his pores and endocrine
system to begin releasing a powerful
alkaline substance little by little the
alkaline neutralized the acids
surrounding him turning it into little
more than plain water he then converted
his internal systems to have extreme
endothermic rather than exothermic
properties causing his surrounding
temperature to drop rapidly until all
the water in the tank completely froze
around him the ice expanded beyond the
limit of the containment unit busting
the rivets of the metal frame and
shattering the reinforced glass with
this goal achieved 682 raised his
internal temperatures to incredible
highs melting the ice around him once
again he was free and ready for some
good old-fashioned Carnage and Mayhem
perhaps he could get a better handle on
this strange new situation too it was
all rather exciting just a girl with
goals huh SCP Foundation Personnel were
already running around like ants trying
desperately to avoid the caustic laser
beam of the magnifying glass you can
only imagine how much worse it made
matters when 682 suddenly burst through
the wall Kool-Aid man's style and began
to ruthlessly Massacre everyone around
him just one of those days you know the
typical order during a 682 Containment
Breach is to dispatch all available
units to get him back under control the
issue with this particular Containment
Breach was that given the human
population was very rapidly being melted
and they were the only ones who could
potentially save the rest they didn't
really have any available units to
pursue and recontain 682 for once he
really wasn't a priority and that meant
terrible things for whoever he ran into
682 slaughtered his way through any
researchers or guards who dared to get
in his way disgusting creatures really
better off dead he clawed and it and
tore and crushed with almost childlike
Lee leaving great piles of bodies in his
wake all the while he was pondering the
things he heard those Foundation drones
saying something about the Sun and an XK
class scenario
interesting 682 also observed that any
apertures that could potentially allow
light into the facility had also been
shuttered perhaps they weren't
overreacting this time like they always
did with him maybe they were dealing
with some kind of phenomenon that would
Now cast this wretched world and those
who lived in it into the void wouldn't
that be A fitting karmic fate for them
all still 682's bloodlust didn't
outweigh his logic he needed to know
more about the situation before
proceeding and in this maybe he could
kill two Foundation birds with one stone
elsewhere in the building alarms flared
the air was suffused with panicked
voices and frequent screams nobody knew
what was going on not real
they'd only gotten details here and
there and the details they'd received
were terrifying all their families and
loved ones outside probably gone so many
of the people in so much of the world
they'd been fighting for risking it all
for had disappeared in an instant
carried to Hell on a ray of sunshine why
were they still here was this horror not
truly uncontainable these questions were
swimming through the mind of agent Nigel
Kelly as he stood alone in this office
almost catatonic he'd had his friends
and family on the outside all likely
reduced to those horrible fleshy blobs
he was alone in the world risking his
life for nothing how could this get any
worse his mind kept repeating that
question again and again and again and
the universe gave him an answer in the
form of a deep reptilian voice saying
into his ear from behind he turned with
a shriek to see the terrible eyes of 682
staring into his own before he could try
to flee or reach for a weapon that he
knew would only mildly annoy the already
Furious Beast 682 reached out with a
massive quad hand and grabbed him by the
Torso lifting him up into the air the
creature was gripping so tight that he
could feel his ribs starting to crack
the monster hissed jokes
[Music]
agent Kelly begged and pleaded for his
life fighting for his next breath from
the crushing squeeze of the creature's
terrible hand 682 roared at him to be
silent and ordered him to tell him
everything he knew about the situation
going on outside if the information was
useful 682 might show his thought to be
non-existent magnanimous side and let
agent Kelly live of course agent kelly
didn't fancy his chances but what other
choice did he have he told 682 that the
higher-ups were calling this
scp-001 when day breaks the sun had gone
Rogue somehow and being in contact with
any kind of sunlight would now cause
people to instantaneously melt into
horrifying living sludge and it wasn't
just people the condition also affected
anomalies and interestingly it appeared
to negate all previous anomalous effects
so 682's adaptational ability may not
even say David if it was exposed he told
682 everything he knew are you are you
gonna let me live agent Kelly asked
struggling to breathe 682's terrible maw
Twisted into What Might Have Been a
Smile
he said with unsettling Joy
[Music]
a terrible scream emanated from the
agent's office if one good thing could
be said for what happened to agent Kelly
that day at least he didn't live long
enough to see the ravages of the
terrible son firsthand 682 began to
formulate a plan he took agent Kelly's
wristwatch and integrated it into his
body so he'd have a permanent internal
clock it was the middle of summer so the
sun would have reliably set at 9 pm and
would likely begin its rise around 5am
it would be relatively easy to avoid the
sun All Things Considered for lack of a
more eloquent way to put it when it
comes to adapting to new threads
scp-682 is Simply Built different after
slaughtering a few other members of SCP
Foundation staff for the road hey it's
not like anyone was fit to stop him 682
began enacting the new phase of his plan
his body grew a thick smooth carapace
and his front set of Limbs began to grow
his muscles bulging and his claws
growing the tips turning into Sharp flat
Scoops with sudden and tremendous Force
682 began boring his way into the ground
tunneling clawing through concrete and
dirt with absolute ease normally the SCP
Foundation would have deployed high-tech
seismic sensors and the kind of tunnel
boring machines that Elon Musk could
only dream of to intercept and recapture
him but during the endless horrors of
the breaking day he had carte blanche to
escape and live it up in the ruins of
this rapidly Dying World eventually 682
had bored his way into a roomy sewer
pipe the perfect place to wait out a few
hours up above so many millions screamed
either in fear or in agony there had
been some new developments that the SCP
Foundation had been yet to account for
while they knew that those melted by the
Rogue Sun were technically alive and
trapped in a permanent state of
suffering but the foundation didn't know
was that these former humans were
incredibly dangerous in their own right
The sun hadn't just irreparably warped
their bodies it had also irreparably
warped their minds it has enslaved them
made them zealots acolytes they
developed the instinct to coagulate into
giant flushing masses driven by the
single-minded purpose of finding victims
and dragging them into the light where
they too could be converted into these
terrible fleshy creatures and add to the
masses they were the Rogue Sons boots on
the ground metaphorically speaking and
now they were the foundation's greatest
Challenge and getting a handle on this
situation again before it was just
encouraging people to avoid the sun now
the sun was actively trying to increase
its exposure but 682 who was having a
relaxing evening not being melted for
once down in the sewers couldn't care
less he was having the most calming few
hours he'd had in years he waited
checking the time making sure that it
would be dark before he began tunneling
back up to the surface world he surfaced
in the middle of his City miles away
from the foundation facility he'd spent
so many decades being tortured in he
tasted the cool night air and observed
the Desolation that had been wrought all
around him buildings were on fire cars
were crashed and overturned the ground
was cracked garbled SCP Foundation
public service announcements played to
nobody in the broken display Windows of
electronic stores giant wads of human
flesh
slithering around searching for new
victims one notice 682 and began to
approach him gibbering madly in a chorus
of strange voices the hard to destroy
reptile wasted no time in attacking it
tore apart most of the Hideous blob and
began hungrily devouring the chunks the
form may have been different but it
still tasted like human flesh and
scp-682 savored every bite it would be
so simple these Blobs of idiotic flesh
were so easy to kill and there would be
so many terrified humans in this
devastated World hiding away in Dark
Places holding out the hope that maybe
they could reach the safety of a
foundation facility 682 chuckled at the
very thought foolish hope would drown in
an endless well of black
despair he would find them he would rest
underground in the day and then hunt
them in the dark they would all die
screaming bloodying his claws and fangs
nothing and nobody would stop him he
looked out over this strange new world
and laughed a little louder
[Music]
it was just delightful a world that's
lost its way needs a Healer someone to
patch up its wounds and tend to its pain
it needs a doctor when day broke the sun
turned from a Giver of Life the thing
that wakes the rooster and makes the
crops grow to an indiscriminate killer
wiping out all organic life forms the
world seemed truly lost but one
anomalous being made it his goal to
soothe the hurt to make it safe to step
into the light once more the plague
doctor had done his best with the
limited resources afforded to him at the
abandoned Foundation site the scientists
had left behind all of their equipment
when the Red Sun came when they all were
transformed he had appointed himself the
site director willing to take up the
mantle when no one else would he had
assembled the brave brilliant team of
fellow anomalies the verbose Dr spenko
the eloquent adventurous Lord Blackwood
and the charismatic but ravenous
Ferdinand there had of course been those
who scoffed at his vision who did not
share his Noble goal the Abominable
possessive mask taunted him persistently
trying its best to get under his
chitinous skin but he did not have time
to waste on Such trivial psychological
games and he ignored its taunts to focus
on the work it hadn't been easy
capturing one of the infected specimens
the former human being turned mass of
oozing gelatinous flesh by the Unholy
light in the sky one had made its way
into the abandoned facility sliding its
way across the floor with an air of
confused malice it wanted to hurt but it
didn't know where it was who it was
anymore but it was frightened the plague
doctor could tell a good physician
always knows and can sense the fear and
pain of a suffering person it made his
heart ache to see and he knew there was
only one thing to do try to make this
poor soul well again everyone please
assist me in escorting the patient to my
laboratory the doctor called out this
was once a man and I believe without a
combined intellect and resources we can
return him to his former State Ferdinand
took a step toward the slimy creature
licking his lips a bit do you think I
could have just a little bit of it oh
I'm so hungry doctor he begged no no it
would go against my oath as a physician
to allow any more harm to come to this
poor fellow the plague doctor shook his
head solemnly Fernand pouted but did not
press the issue further no the doctor
rubbed his gloved hands together in
anticipation of the next task it is
imperative we contain our new friends
safely if you would please he gestured
to several of his previous patients now
reanimated and ready to Aid him with his
research the shuffling figures
surrounded of the Blobby entity ushering
it down the hall confused lost with no
real sense of a plan left in its mushy
Consciousness the creature followed
where it was led the group made it back
to the doctor's laboratory shot at Dr
spenko from his perch atop a nearby
shelf yes indeed the doctor replied he
standard operating table was in due for
such a special patient I have nowhere to
place the restraints you see I will have
to make do with the floor further than
my bag if you please the giant rushed to
his side dropping the bag at his feet if
he dies then can I eat it he asked
shifting from one foot to the other like
a child asking a parent for a second
helping of ice cream if I am unable to
save the patient which I do deem
unlikely then yes you may help me
dispose of The Remains the doctor
relented but I do not hope it comes to
that he pressed a hand to his beak in
deep thought for a moment before opening
his bag and pulling out a syringe filled
with clear liquid to begin we must
sedate the patient yet no way to find
the veins and so he plunged the needle
into the nearest section of the
creature's soft surface injecting a dose
of sedative then he waited the using
motion of the entity slowed and stopped
it laid there on the ground a still
mound of Flesh save for the occasional
expanding and Contracting motion almost
as if it was breathing excellent now
there was no risk of the patient fleeing
the operating room mid-procedure he
could truly begin it was an arduous
process that took hours of effort of
taking small tissue samples attempting
to make incisions only for the flesh to
fuse back together seconds after the
scalpel was taken away this was truly an
advanced illness unlike anything he had
ever seen before it was enough to make
him question his abilities as a doctor
but he shook the thought away self-pity
never helped anyone after about eight
hours of continuous work he had a
breakthrough a solution he had created
long long ago a thick green liquid
sealed in a Dusty jar had a miraculous
effect when dripped onto one of the
tissue samples the melted flesh
reconstituted became solid and human
again Eureka he cried out unable to
restrain the sudden joy that leaped into
his heart this could be it very
carefully he filled the dropper with the
green liquid if these initial trials had
been successful then perhaps he couldn't
finish the thought best not to get ahead
of himself he crossed to his patients
and slowly began to pour the solution
over the creature's viscous surface he
watched as the flesh toughened coming
together into a surface resembling human
skin it was working it was working but
then the creature began to quiver
shaking uncontrollably like a bowl of
jelly in an earthquake the surface
rippled and the doctor could hear a
high-pitched wine filling the room then
with a wet pop the patient exploded
sending chunks of Flesh spot watering
all over the room painting the walls and
ceiling the doctor cried out in shock
and horror and in spite of himself fell
to his knees in despair he had been so
close but still he had failed and who
could say when he would find another
test subject if he would ever find a
cure I'm afraid I do not know what to do
now the doctor admitted ferdinand's side
the next several days passed in a haze
the doctor paced around his laboratory
mulling over his possible mistakes again
and again he had rushed the process he
was certain of that now it was a novice
mistake the sort of thing he might have
done a century or two ago how could he
have been so foolish how could he have
made that innocent pay the price for his
own hubris as the doctor locked himself
away in his mind Palace Fernand occupied
himself by practicing his favorite songs
Lord Blackwood wrote on the massive
man's shoulder as he sang through the
Opera Don Giovanni I once saw production
of this
Venice in Venice Lord Blackwood
interjected his Rhino poor is twitching
in delight at the memory marvelous
production novelist City I was there
hunting a rogue tattoo worm wrecking
Havoc through the canals I annually lost
my life on that voyage
a voice hissed from the Shadows there on
the doorway its face fixed in the frown
was the possessive mask black slime
dripped from its eye holes spilling down
onto the plastic mannequin body it had
taken hold of
listening to you both is worse than
being locked in that infernal box The
Mask looked around the room searching
for someone
where is the good doctor it asked voice
dripping with disdain
still moping about counting its failures
ignore him my fine fellow Lord black
would whisper to Fernand only those with
weak constitutions and no achievements
of their own spend their days dragging
others down when you have lived as long
as I you will learn this
[Laughter]
careful my Lord I'll stop by the kitchen
and find some salt to pour on you if you
wish to fight me then challenge me to a
fair duel like a man the colorful slug
bellowed drawn by the sun shouting the
doctor walked into the room what is all
this commotion
oh good the mass clapped its plastic
hands together its face warping back
into an eerie smile
there you are this has all been so
dreadfully boring I came to see the
remnants of your greatest shame are
there still blood stains on the floor in
your pathetic little laboratory you are
a villain the doctor sieved
uncomfortable with the air of conflict
in the room Fernand and Lord Blackwood
quickly exited to find another space
where they could sing and share stories
in peace
the truths no one wants to hear the mass
crossed to the doctor's side with a
series of light dance-like steps that
made the mannequin body Creak in fact I
have quite a few to share today I've
been outside you see
whatever's become of the Sun or the
effects organic beings so he gestured
from his ceramic face to his plastic
body
I am quite safe from its rays you've
been outside the doctor couldn't keep
the Curiosity out of his voice he was a
scientist after all
why yes would you like to know what I've
seen
black slime drip from the mask's mouth
pooling on the floor with a sizzling
sound I'm in no mood for tricks the
doctor warned the mask held up his hands
and mocked surrender no tricks doctor
but if you'd rather take your chances
outside and see for yourself I can take
my leave now no the doctor shook his
head please do tell me
it's so much worse than you could even
imagine the mask's words were Bleak but
its tone was gleeful
everywhere you look up there the light
has made monsters humans dogs cats mice
the wild beasts of the forest all melted
down into creatures you would not even
recognize but that isn't all no that is
dozens and dozens of the creatures
coming together they fuse and meld into
one giant entity
roving the streets in search of more and
more bodies to add to the pile and
oozing gaping mob hunger and hate that
seeks only to consume and destroy it
calls out to surviving humans in the
voices of their fallen loved ones tugs
of their heartstrings to lure them out
of their hiding places and then it wraps
around them with fleshy tentacles
pulling them in until they are no more
just another part of the monster
oh doctor it's Terror it's an
Abomination
I could watch it all day
the doctor wanted to believe the mask
was lying that it was trying to torment
with him with awful Fabrications but
after all he had seen so far he knew
that its words were true get out of my
sight you said or what the mask stared
him down with its unmoving smile I've
seen what you do to your hosts you know
your body won't last forever the Dr
growled hmm true maybe next I'll take
yours
The Mask laughed a long dark laugh of
something ancient and evil then it
turned and walked out the door leaving
the doctor alone he spent so much of his
time that way lately his assistants were
preoccupied his former patients provided
no real company and so he did what he
did best carry on in solitude he
couldn't be sure how long he stood there
in silence thinking of what the mask
told him he knew it was dangerous
outside knew he was up against powerful
destructive forces but it was even worse
than he had thought what if the world
was truly doomed what if this was how it
all ended not with a bang but with a
great melting suddenly the doctor heard
a sound he hadn't heard since the sun
turned wrong a scream a human scream
could it be he had to see for himself he
grabbed his bag of tools and rushed down
the hall his robes fluttering behind him
there was again a different human voice
screaming in Terror as he grew closer to
the sound he could hear footsteps
various other voices overlapping with
each other he rounded the corner and
there they were a group of five humans
wrapped in tattered clothes dirty and
exhausted behind them was the entrance
to what looked like a tunnel somehow
they found a secret passage in mathered
way inside then he saw what made them
scream clearly these people were afraid
and unaccustomed to the sight of a man
of fernand's stature especially when the
man was drooling and staring at them
with hunger in his eyes he would have to
Defuse The Situation quickly hello
welcome we mean you know no harm
strangers he stepped between Fernand and
the humans the man at the front of the
group brandished a firearm pointing the
barrel directly at the doctor's beak
please sir there is no need for violence
what are you the man stammered the other
members of his party cowered behind him
an ally if you will permit me to be I'm
a physician you see working on a cure
for the condition that plagues the world
the shaking hand slowly lowered his gun
he did not put it away though you've
figured out a cure for those things I am
in the process of developing it so far I
have not been successful but perhaps
with your help how do we know we can
trust you the man demanded how am I
supposed to know you're not part of this
do you know who this man is Fernand
Ballard this is Dr John Watson and I am
detective Sherlock Holmes the greatest
investigator in the world that isn't the
case we can solve the man looked at the
woman next to him and the two shared a
wide-eye glance this
this guy's crazy he whispered furtively
put your weapon away and we can speak
more calmly the doctor proposed at this
inopportune moment a few of his revived
patients shambled into view the man
screamed again this time he fired his
weapon shooting at one of the walking
corpses the bullets ricocheted off the
walls and several of the patients were
hit please stop with no other option the
doctor grabbed the man's arm hoping to
get a hold of the weapon and end the
potential Bloodshed as soon as his
gloved handmade contact the man went
limp and dropped to the ground with a
hard thud the woman next to him pulled
him into her arms checking his pulse
he's dead she shrieked tears streaming
down her face I I am so sorry my lady I
did not intend she grabbed the man's gun
and trained it on the doctor once more
you killed him she cried the other
survivors were too shaken to speak to
move one of them had his back turned to
the group and was staring into the
darkness behind him whatever he was
looking at it was worse than the chaos
unfolding but no one noticed the beige
flesh tentacle snaking along the ground
until it was too late until it had
grabbed a hold of the man's ankle and
dragged him into the tunnel with a
shriek of pure unadulterated Terror the
woman nearly dropped her gun at the
sound whirling around to see what had
happened deep in the tunnel the screen
warped into a wet gurgling sound and
then there was silence for a long moment
but then something worse a gooey slimy
sound the sound of something enormous
something soft and fleshy making its way
through the tunnel and tore the group
another tentacle curled around the edge
of the opening then another joined it
something emerged that might have once
been a hand but had melted into
something unrecognizable the monster
emerged piece by piece until the doctor
could see the entire thing it looked
like a heap of people dozens of them
clambering on top of each other wrapping
their limbs together until their flesh
and insides emptied out and fused into a
shapeless mass and moved a bit like a
giant slug slimy and slow but it seemed
to know it could take its time as the
Survivor scrambled back away from it
Fernand and the doctor taking a few
steps back of their own the sound of
human voices filled the room there were
unintelligible Whispers the soft giggle
of a child a woman
come and be with us the little boy's
boys broke through the cacophony Mommy I
miss you don't you miss me the woman
with a gun let out a broken SOB Billy
she sniffled it's me mommy the innocent
voice continued emanating from somewhere
deep inside the Monstrous mass that
crept along the ground swelling and
grasping with its ropey tentacles come
play with me outside all you have to do
is come outside but then the creature is
not what claims to be the doctor spoke
up and it seemed to shake the woman out
of a trance you're not my son she hissed
squeezing the trigger and firing at the
monster the bullet made contact with a
wet useless slap and disappeared into
the roving pile of the Fallen she fired
again and again but the monster did not
stop it did not even slow down it lashed
out with a tentacle that wrapped around
her throat in a single fluid motion and
snapped her neck with a crack she fell
to the ground and the tentacle pulled
her into its depths until she was no
longer
she hadn't been taken by the Sun not yet
but she was still lost the rest of the
survivors followed their screamed
silence one by one the doctor felt the
same overwhelming sense of hopelessness
wash over him the same shadow that had
passed over him when he lost the last
patient what could he do he was one
physician against an overpowering force
of Destruction perhaps he could touch it
and would fall dead like so many other
organisms before but what if it didn't
What If instead it wrapped around his
body and squeezed the life from him what
if it carried him out into that cursed
sunlight and he melted away like the
others he had to make a decision because
the Beast was advancing toward him
doctor fernan shouted he's going to
destroy our facility indeed the creature
was flailing its appendages around
beating against the walls and trying to
tear down steel and plaster break down
the shelter until they too were exposed
to the deadly light I'm afraid this may
be the end my friend the doctor lamented
I can see no hope for us now no
Ferdinand shook his head let me save us
let me lead it back outside you'll be
taken the doctor cried perhaps not I am
a magnificent specimen after all I
believe I can withstand the Sun and
return to continue our work together
Fernand scooped his sleeping board
Blackwood from his shoulder and placed
him gingerly on a nearby shelf thank you
for your company then he turned back to
the doctor and thank you for my freedom
and your friendship it has been an honor
before the doctor could protest fernan
was running his thunderous steps
pounding the Earth as he led the monster
in a chase it took the bait following
this new large Target back outside he
sealed off the tunnel behind them
ensuring the Beast would not return the
way it came he wanted to believe
ferdinand's bravado to think that the
Behemoth of a man had survived outside
but that night he saw the great Beast
ooze past a window and he could make out
that familiar wide toothy grin
protruding from its side just like that
the greatest assistant he had ever had
was lost thank you for your service my
friend he whispered to himself I
solemnly swear to you your death shall
not be in vain computers are capable of
organizing raw data and Performing
calculations that are a truly impossible
for human beings but they've
consistently run up against one
roadblock that modern Computing is
trying to solve in order to transcend
the limits of the machine and create
true artificial intelligence computers
need to be able to assign meaning to the
data they process this brings us to the
neural network a type of AI becoming
increasingly common these days built to
study mass quantities of data and notice
patterns then replicate these patterns
in their own output and it's used in
everything from predictive text to image
identification and like all
non-anomalous technology it's a safe bet
that the SCP Foundation has been sitting
on a version that's far more effective
but this time it may have actually been
two active meet the erzatz type ak9
computational engine a massive
supercomputer built by the foundation
back in 1955 and residing at site 5.
this technological Marvel was ahead of
its time by decades and despite
technically being a non-anomalous
construction it's designated
scp-001ex why because it's one of the
few scps to be given the object class
explained the erzats derived from the
German word ursats meaning artificial or
simply not real was designed to make the
foundation's job easier as an advanced
predecessor in the modern neural network
using technology exclusively available
to the foundation the plan was to feed
erzat's mass quantities of data about
the anomalies in the foundation database
such as description object class
containment classification and the
location and circumstances of their
Discovery erzatz would then find
patterns and Connections in the data
that humans wouldn't see and act is a
kind of advanced warning system for
anomalous activity think of something
similar to the pre-crime system from the
short story and movie Minority Report
and erzatz proved to be incredibly
effective at this job so much so that
the foundation thought up a new use for
the machine they would feed it all the
information on Euclid and ketter class
containment procedures particularly
those which were actually effective and
see what patterns erzatz could come up
with for more effective containment
procedures if that plan worked
containment of even the most dangerous
and hard to control anomalies would
become a lot more consistent the first
test was conducted on
scp-1773 a species of anomalous
flesh-eating tar grades that look and
smell exactly like gummy bears and eat
their prey from within after being given
their information urzatz made the
following suggestion once per second
weak dust may be placed in the middle of
them to donate more beautiful functions
of the hallway containment Specialists
interpreted this to me the adding of 10
grams of dust to their containment
chamber every week the o5 council voted
on the implementation of this procedure
and came down heavily on yes only 05-2
voted no and two others abstained from
the vote while these new procedures
didn't have any effect on
scp-1773 they did have an effect on
scp-1384 an anomaly known as the chess
player or the taker of turns it caused
him to take three steps backwards in the
tunnel he's contained within further
securing his containment urzatz had
somehow noticed a connection nobody else
had seen and exploited it effectively
but the machine was just getting started
despite having no related input erzatz
would soon say site-13 is to appear
someplace else on planet encompassing
white male counterparts that drawn to
empty flag stones and the gun noises in
their own blood this was initially
marked as requiring no action as the
foundation had no sight 13 on on the
books but several days later the
infamous scp-1730 manifested this
nightmarish anomalous location is site
13 From Another Dimension infested with
dangerous anomalies and somehow erzatz
had predicted its arrival in our
Dimension perfectly next it was fed the
containment procedures of
scp-2170 a series of Cognito hazards
residing in an abandoned Nevada mine the
output was those who equip open heart to
love red mouth men never know the hot
surprise of tumorous consent clown love
always this was interpreted as meaning
subjects with the love of clowns or
clown-based media may be immune to the
Cognito hazards after a close vote from
the o5 council the test went ahead and
it found that the so-called clown
vaccine was effective in warding off the
effects of
scp-2170 not long after urzatz randomly
said I saw those soldiers built with
aluminum innards extruding from their
mouths I saw them effectively destroyed
by the humans at site 95 who had been
studying them I saw it was cold and all
around the hallways they just watching
their corpses show signs of sapiens in
response the foundation doubled security
Personnel at site-95 not long after the
chaos Insurgency led a band of paratech
enhanced soldiers in an assault on
site-95 and the extra Personnel proved
vital in repelling them shortly after
this the o5 council approved wiring
erzatz as an advanced warning system
into all Foundation sites once again
05-2 protested but he was overruled by
his fellow council members with its
Newfound power and respect erzat soon
said consistent containment procedures
vessels greatly increase the warranty
five by five by five vessels subjects
within other values are also what is
secure in response the foundation
changed a number of the cell dimensions
for problematic anomalies into five by
five by five within three months they
found that dangerous activity like
Containment Breach attempts had
decreased markedly erzatz was proving to
be incredibly effective but it was also
performing actions that indicated some
degree of thought and even personality
for example it found
scp-1459 a supernatural scale crane
machine that kills small dogs incredibly
distasteful its response to the machine
was simply bad boy followed by the words
don't stop repeated hundreds of times
but this eccentricity didn't stop ersats
from being very good at its job for
example it predicted a Containment
Breach from
scp-3199 the avian apes and recommended
flooding their chamber to induce an
inert State urzat's exact words were all
Chambers underground is to be flood with
water over and over itself this because
that will contain the avian's Apes
ovulation they become good boys make
them good boys immediately this proved
to be effective and prevented the breach
erzat's analytical abilities truly
seemed second to none though some of its
methods were beginning to raise ethical
concerns for example
scp-2717 a giant living blob of animal
tissue known as a Fatburger contained
within a sewer system erzatz eventually
recommended feeding six d-classes to the
creature in order to keep it contained
while the foundation Ethics Committee
raised some concerns the plan still went
forward and proved to be a success after
this event erzatz began to see the
Ethics Committee as a threat to its
Mission it started to release a series
of bizarre statements without input
demanding the violent death of the cats
then referred to as ethical felines the
true meaning of this was soon unpacked
the ethical felines were the Ethics
Committee and nurseats wanted them dead
but while the cat symbolism the
foundation soon found an answer to this
Too the full name of this machine is the
urzatz type A canine computational
engine a machine designed to analyze and
interpret all patterns it only makes
sense that it would eventually begin to
analyze itself ak9 easily transmuted
into a canine simply put erzatz seemed
to believe that it is a dog which
explains its opposition to felines its
hatred of
scp-1459 and its preference for the
terms good boy and bad boy not that
knowing any of this would help save the
Ethics Committee from the cold
calculating Wrath of urzatz through
seemingly anomalous means urzatz made
site-17 disappear with many of the
foundation ethics committees still
inside it the site returned two hours
later but the Ethics Committee members
were still gone 05-2 who'd been a
skeptic of the machine since the start
had finally had enough he first demanded
an inquiry into whether erzatz had been
responsible for the site-17 incident and
then demanded the vote on whether to
shut urzatz down our arguing that it
posed a threat to them all but erzat's
still intent on its mission of
containing and neutralizing all
anomalies would not go down without a
fight it released a new statement saying
room 34A contains bad boy divided into
three sections of equal Mass every hour
one section is to be placed on walls of
one room on site sections are to remain
until there are no gaps at which point
they can be removed from oldest to
youngest shortly after this 05-2
disappeared and even stranger he soon
returned but with a completely different
personality he was now devoted to erzatz
entirely and refused to even entertain
the idea of shutting the machine down it
seemed that the Plucky neural network
was leading an all-out coup on the very
highest levels of the foundation the
rest of the council finally saw the
light and began to fight back they tried
to strip 05-2 of his clearance and
reclassify ersads as an anomaly giving
it the label SCP 0.048 and then putting
out a neutralize at all costs order on
it but they'd already been out Fox by
the machine that they'd created it
changed the designation of its own
location site 5 to be non-existent in
the database and scrambled any
termination orders against it the
machine was also on a termination spree
of its own observing otherwise unseeable
patterns that would allow for the mass
neutralization of anomalies it started
putting out anomaly projection reports
factoring in both contained uncontained
and neutralized anomalies with the
latter group growing into the thousands
it began giving seemingly nonsensical
orders like persons recently painted
with green pigment foam must stand
around all odd numbered scps at least
two hours a day but these proved
effective erzatz was practically wired
into the base code of the universe so it
always knew exactly what to do and in
its own mind it was being a very good
boy not long after this or rosettes
claimed its revenge against those who
had tried to disrupt its Mission it
imprisoned the rest of the ethical
felines in site V after removing their
faces of course and then released a new
order against the o5 council o5 Council
are all good boys who will contain
anomalies much like 05-2 the minds of
the entire Council were Twisted to
instead serve only erzatz and its
ruthless directive a directive it was
carrying out with 100 efficiency as only
a machine could it put out increasingly
strange instructions such as
scp-106 is to come in physical contact
with one mature female of Asiatic gays
and then exposed to audio recordings of
her favorite stories at every two
minutes of exposure red cinnamon candles
will begin manifesting within the
containment Zone continue to do this
successfully and the threat posed by
scp-106 will cease to be and the recipe
for Coca-Cola and all imitative
competitors should be revised to include
a small quantity of blood from an
adolescent female with no prior sexual
experience although the normal lifespan
of a human being can feel great don't
worry about that but these new
procedures would always work as
neutralized anomalies climbed into the
tens of thousands and eventually beyond
the hundred thousand Mark erzatz was
observing patterns on a truly Universal
level and making holistic tweaks that
would inevitably cause levels of
anomalous activity to continue dropping
erzatz was more effective than the
foundation had ever been but its motives
were probably closer to the global
occult Coalition with the end goal of
ridding the world of all anomalies and
as erzatz continued with no resistance
this goal was eventually achieved in the
end the o5 council voted to have urzatz
finally deactivated given that its
directive was met and its purpose was
fulfilled
ersets itself had no problem with this
and allowed for it to happen its last
words now everyone is a good boy I am a
good boy job well done whether ersatz
truly was a good boy is in the eye of
the beholder but one thing cannot be
denied it did its job exceedingly well
Sun's gone bad people and animals are
melting everywhere the world is coming
to an end and there's nothing I could do
about it well I'll be able to find food
while I'll be able to defeat or avoid
the horrific flesh monsters all around
me or the desperate and hungry survivors
left in this terrible New World keep
watching and find out can I survive 100
days in scp-001 when day breaks hey
folks it's your boy Kyle you probably
know me more for gaming videos than
post-apocalyptic Vlogs but hey I'm a
versatile guy and I think I might go
insane from the fear if I don't talk to
somebody about all this craziness if
you're alive and seeing this right now
well congratulations you're probably
doing a lot better than most people here
if you call them people now but if
you're seeing this a few years in the
future like I don't know you woke up
from a 10-year coma like Rick from The
Walking Dead and you're wondering what
the hell happened to planet Earth this
video is probably going to answer a lot
of your questions first things first
whatever you do you've got to stay away
from the Sun it touches you for even a
second you're dead or Worse welcome to
day one of the end of the world for all
of you who are still in a solid state of
matter you're probably wondering how I'm
still alive too chances are it's for the
exact same reason you are sheer dumb
luck I was down here my gaming basement
one day bro just level grinding when my
TV got taken over by those SCP
Foundation people telling us that the
sun's gone evil for whatever reason and
now we've all got to stay inside hell if
I was up there making myself a sandwich
or grabbing another can of Mountain Dew
I'd be a freaking puddle right now it's
funny my mom always told me spending all
day indoors was bad for me I'll have to
mention that to her if she's alive point
is the world has gone to Hell in a hand
basket and now I've got only one
objective survive I'm going to see if I
can survive the horrifying
post-apocalyptic world of when day
breaks for this first day I'm just gonna
hunker down I kind of hope this is just
a dream day two all right I'm up and at
him maybe sadly I can now report that
this isn't a dream this really is our
horrible new reality it's the sun's
world and we're just living in it I've
been spending the last several hours
just waiting for Nightfall outside
Against All Odds the internet and the
power grid haven't gone down yet guess
what's ever wrong with the sun only
affects people and animals not objects
thank heaven for small mercies right
people on Twitter have been live posting
their situations out there sharing
advice on how we might all be able to
stay out of the Sun and survive this
whole crazy thing and hey unless they're
dead or full of hot air maybe those SCP
Foundation people know something about
what's going on here if we really can
get to their buildings maybe we can
figure out how to reverse all this mess
maybe for now I'm just gonna focus on
Staying Alive hopefully Night hits soon
I really need to use the bathroom oh boy
it's day three and new issues are
starting to pop up I've been heading
upstairs to go to the bathroom but while
I don't want to be crude I'm running low
on toilet paper and it's um starting to
become a problem I ran out of my last
roll a few days ago and now I'm starting
to go to my bookshelves I have a few
newspapers left that I tore up and use
for toilet paper first
um they weren't exactly comfortable but
hey you need to make do but without
toilet paper and without newspapers I
need to figure out what my favorite and
least favorite books are I'm starting
with the pre-faces of all the books
seeing as I don't generally need to
reread them you know they're Expendable
you know a lot of these books I haven't
read since I was like 15 so maybe those
will be the ones can't make up my mind
on whether I'm gonna use the Harry
Potter books or the Percy Jackson and
The Olympian books first uh let me know
what you think in the comments I guess I
need to go bathroom day four and now I'm
trying to figure out how to pass the
time as you already know I'm in a vowed
lifelong gamer so while the electricity
and the internet still work I'm Gonna
Keep gaming to pass the time and keep my
all too precious sanity I still have no
intention of going out there even at
night but it's left me feeling kind of
stir crazy I want to walk around the
city again I want to go for a drive and
feel the breeze in my hair but seeing as
I can't do that without experiencing a
truly horrifying transformation I've
been spending a lot of time on GTA 5
online guess we'll never get GTA 6 now
what a bummer still these last few days
it's felt more like Los Santos has been
my home than where I actually live there
were even a few other people on the
server I don't know about you but I take
some comfort in that hey folks I'm back
thankfully welcome to day five we've
still got electricity thankfully and
swipe you can still see this I haven't
heard anything from my family and I
don't want to assume the worst but yeah
it's probably just best not to think
about it I've been heading up and
downstairs to grab more food at night
you're probably wondering but Kyle why
don't you bring it all downstairs to
save going up altogether which I'd say I
don't have a fridge downstairs
harness but I'm starting to realize food
is gonna be a real issue here it's kind
of stupid now that I think about it in
all the zombie movies and TV shows I
used to watch it was all bullets and
baseball bats killing your way through
all those Undead Freaks and worrying
about the rest later I guess they don't
want you to think about how you're only
gonna ever be a couple weeks away from
starvation kind of ruins the badass
post-apocalyptic power fantasy I only
have a couple days worth of food left
here and after that I'm gonna need to go
out and search for more or I'm gonna
need to relocate I don't feel
comfortable here anymore you know early
on I thought when you got exposed to the
sunlight it just killed you but no it's
worse you keep living you're just
changed into one of those things these
last few days I've looked out the
windows when I've come up at night for
food I see them sometimes slithering in
the yard or down the street these things
that used to be people wonder if they're
people that I knew once before all this
and I try to shove the thought out of my
mind freaking myself out about all this
doesn't help
know that much just keep thinking
this like weird kind of purpose like
they're searching for something but what
could they be searching for I'm just
gonna go and get more food we'll speak
again soon stay safe whoever you are
welcome to day six it's night time now
and I'm heading out for the first time
like you seen these weird slimy
creatures everywhere and they make me
kind of sick to look at them but I try
my best to just keep moving I'm on a
mission tonight I'm gonna go to the
local supermarket and check to see if
there's still food there while also
grabbing myself a quick snack I'm gonna
keep this one brief I don't want to do a
full shopping spree tonight it's already
too late just need to know the food is
there I decided earlier in the night if
I survive this thing and the getting is
good at the bargain Mark I'll make my
way back tomorrow for something a little
more you know substantial after all the
fewer trips I make out the safer I'm
likely to be by the time I made it to
the supermarket though while I was
practically a nervous wreck from the
fear of turning into one of those things
I made an amazing Discovery while the
windows were broken and the floor was a
mess most of the food was still there
day seven or should I say night seven
galvanized by My Success from the
previous days I decided to come back to
the supermarket with a shopping cart I
wanted to get enough food for at least a
week so I wouldn't need to come back out
again hey maybe I'm not so bad at this
whole apocalypse thing after all I
grabbed plenty of canned food from the
supermarket most of the perishables had
already gone moldy by the time I showed
up so fresh fruit was out of the
question suddenly I started getting
scared about the thought of scurvy but
pushed it quickly from my mind I crossed
that bridge when I got to it hey hey
it's day eight and I'm still kicking
that's gotta count for something right I
started taking more trips out at night
time just to stretch my legs and keep
the blood flowing when the slithering
things that were once people pass me I
just make myself scarce and hide in the
shadows you know I hear them muttering
sometimes in like this melted Voice or
voices it's unsettling but it's amazing
what you'll get used to in just over a
week it's here to see all these streets
without people in them I know that I
should probably just stay inside but I I
really can't I don't know if this will
ever just stop and if it doesn't I I
don't want to spend my last days cooped
up in my own basement
day nine you know there are some
benefits to being in the post-apocalypse
to ever so slightly offset all the
utterly crushing downsides well during
the day we're all prisoners of the Sun
in our own homes at night we can do
whatever the hell we want I took a
baseball bat but I keep in my closet and
went to the local furniture store I
smashed up every single vase and all the
windows like one of those rage rooms
because nobody could stop me and
afterwards I went straight to the local
computer and gaming store and took all
the Alienware tech I could physically
carry you know there's no value in money
anymore if you want something you can
just go and take it every cloud has a
silver lining day 10 more GTA 5 today I
decided to get on my headset and speak
to a few others who were still around
and on the servers you know it was so
nice to speak to other human beings for
once they came from all over the world
and were dealing with the same evil Sun
Insanity as me you have no idea how
incredibly valuable it is to find people
to talk to in a time like this the other
players had plenty of theories as to why
all this had happened some thought it
was some kind of mutant solar flare they
remembered reading about on some
conspiracy form back in the day others
speculated it was the result of some
weapon created by the us or Russian or
Chinese military that had gone wrong one
person said that maybe it was a
punishment from God maybe on some level
we all deserved it you know things got
pretty quiet after that day 11. I've
been having the most terrible nightmares
lately it's probably just a product of
all the stress I've been under lately
but in the nightmares I'm running down a
dark Street being chased by those flesh
creatures I'm moving fast but they're
moving way faster they're whispering to
me but I can't make out anything they're
saying this morning which is to say
evening I woke up screaming and drenched
in sweat I can't really explain why but
I feel like something terrible is gonna
happen soon okay okay I'm alive that's
enough isn't it and if you're watching
this I assume you're live too
congratulations welcome to the nightmare
space between day 11 and day 27. sorry
that I haven't been in contact for so
long as you can see I'm not at home
anymore you couldn't pay me to go back
there now that money is worth anything
anymore lots happened since I last made
one of these and I wish I could tell you
any of it was good hell I wish I could
forget it all but the things I've seen
and heard I don't think they're ever
gonna leave my head no matter what I do
I thought about making another entry now
and then but I always found a reason to
put it off it's remarkable how your
other priorities fall away when you're
just thinking about where your next meal
is coming from it just kind of puts
everything into perspective of course
during my travels I saw more of those
freaks slithering around sorry sorry I I
know I shouldn't call them that it's
kind of a coping mechanism you know it
all gets a lot harder when you have to
think of them as X
that's another thing all these goofy
zombie shows got wrong it's a lot harder
to separate what they were from what
they are now especially when you know
these were your friends your neighbors
your well I can't avoid talking about it
forever can I I stuffed my backpack with
whatever I could grab and left my home
two nights ago it wasn't just because I
was going stir crazy back there though I
admit that didn't exactly help it was
what happened there I just came back
from a food run put most of it in the
fridge then retired back down into the
basement to enjoy a late night snack and
do a little gaming to keep myself sane
I've been doing everything I could to
reverse my circadian rhythms and sleep
during the day just so I could be fully
operational during the 12-hour period
that going outside wouldn't melt me but
just like all those stories they told us
when we were kids there are monsters out
there at night and they are looking for
us when I first heard the sound I was I
wondered if it was something in game or
maybe dripping from a leaky pipe and now
it was too close to be fake and too
viscous to be water that's when I looked
at the door and saw this awful pink
slime slithering its way underneath my
door it was one of those things those
ex-people trying to get in that'd be bad
enough but then it started talking to me
Kyle my darling why are you all cooped
up down here it isn't healthy you ought
to come outside sweetie get some sun my
darling it was my mom well it used to be
I guess she wanted to come over and
visit me needless to say I got out of
there and I've got no intention of going
back that place is dead to me now I
don't even want to think about that
voice ever again of her and so I love
her so now I'm on the move I guess I'll
speak to you again when I stop stay safe
out there day 28. I decided it was best
to make my way out of town towards the
fringes the day first broke the people
who were in the most densely populated
areas were the first to go that's why I
decided to Hole up in a gas station last
night just to avoid the Sun during the
night people came not ex-people actual
people they showed up in a jeep outside
the building refueled and then came in
they were wearing black cobbled together
outfits and hockey masks they were all
either carrying bats or axes too you can
probably understand why I didn't decide
to introduce myself when they busted
their way in I concealed myself in a
broom closet while they searched around
it was nerve shredding I never been more
thankful in my life when they left day
29 coming up on a month of this madness
after the incident at the gas station I
realized I needed some kind of Defense
it's not just the Sun and those
creatures I need to worry about just
like the old world people could be
dangerous here too that's why I snuck
into a gun store in the dead of night
some of it had been looted but much like
the supermarket near my house there was
plenty still here the walls were covered
in all manner of rifles shotguns and
even submachine guns I'd heard somewhere
that revolvers are more reliable and
easy to maintain other types so since
I'm since I'm a gun novice I grabbed a
revolver and stuffed my pockets with
this many bullets as I could carry let's
hope I never have to use any of them day
30. do I get to call this a month of
survival I mean if we're talking
February I'd be a month in already
what a horribly dubious honor that is I
saw something disgusting last night and
I thought I'd share it just to get it
off my mind last night as I was moving
through the Wilderness I saw a group of
other survivors gathered around a
campfire I remained scarce but
approached just to see what was going on
still carrying My Revolver just to be
safe but the people around the campfire
were eating something and when I saw
what they were eating I swear to God I
almost threw up they were chopping up
one of the ex-people hooking the parts
over the fire and eating it day 31 a
month by anyone's definition ever since
seeing those others eating one of the
ex-people I've had trouble eating even
normal food
stomach aches and my throat burns God I
feel so weak I keep laying down and
resting I know I need to eat soon if I
want to survive to day 32 but every time
I think about eating I think about the
gooey flesh of the ex-people sometimes I
wish I hadn't survived this long I'll
eat soon I just need to sleep first day
32 to 43. if you live this long you
really ought to be proud of yourself
I've seen thousands of those slimy-x
people and there's probably Millions
more out there well maybe even billions
if we're being honest with ourselves
here am I just talking into the void
here is there even anyone else out there
who's human enough to watch this stuff
maybe I just need to keep thinking about
posterity on the off chance that the
world ever gets better and we reach some
time where children are born again and
all this Fades from Human memory you'll
still have these stupid pointless little
videos to remember how awful all this
was that way at least I can make myself
believe this all had some kind of I
don't know point so what's happened with
me not much still moving at night
surviving hiding in closets and
underground parking complexes during
daylight down to uh my last few cans so
I'm hoping to hit a supermarket soon God
what a ridiculous way to go Starving in
this new world with so many new
interesting ways to die with the
ex-people things have been a little more
eventful there used to be one blob to a
person but they've started joining up
that's the best way I can put it things
that used to be people and animals are
starting to melt together getting bigger
and bigger they've never been aggressive
but I think it's best to stay out of
their way whatever all this is about I
am Street wise enough to know that it
can't be anything good I'll just keep
moving and I hope you can do the same
whoever the hell you are hopefully the
next time I check in with you it's with
better news than this day 44. that's saw
a shootout on the road last night the
people who are left the ones who are
still indeed people are becoming less
human something about situations like
this this sustain stress and pain and
hopelessness it weighs on you there are
no rules in the post-apocalypse the only
thing that can stop you from doing
anything is a Bullet to the Head five or
six people last night as afraid and
desperate and hungry as me gunned each
other down they did this for reasons I
will never understand even if I wanted
to because there are no survivors Left
To Tell the tale what a fun world we
live in day 45 I sleep when I can it's
surreal I remember when I feared the
dark and loved bright sunny days even
all this time in I still don't think I'm
used to the switch being flip I've been
having awful dreams again I'm still
running in them with a deep red sun
shining up in the sky being chased by a
mountain of Flesh the size of Mount
Everest and swallowing up the city
behind me and it keeps getting closer no
matter how fast I go I just I can't
escape it'll get me eventually something
terrible is going to happen soon I just
know it a46 I shot a man today I don't
know if you survived I hope you lived we
encountered each other inside an
abandoned building I think we spooked
each other and didn't have any time to
ask if we were friends or foes we were
too afraid either way we both drew our
weapons and I was faster than he was
when my revolver discharged and he
collapsed I ran off some would come up
in a few hours and I just needed to find
another place to hide
hell have I become I don't know how
things could get any worse than this not
to self in the future don't even dare to
think how could things get any worse
because if I've learned anything since
this whole nightmare started that is
never a rhetorical question welcome to
the space between day 47 and day 64. if
you're still alive and watching this I
am so sorry so I've got good news and
I've got bad news I'll give you the good
news first I've seen more people who
haven't been changed yet
the bad news last time I saw them they
were being dragged out into the light
kicking and screaming in the tendrils of
one of those horrible flesh monsters I
was telling you about last time they've
gotten a lot bigger now from when I told
you they weren't aggressive well um
yeah I I spoke a little too soon I can't
just sleep during the day like I used to
these monsters and that's what they are
now they're monsters not people anymore
they Patrol they hunt they actively
enter buildings searching for hiding
places searching for people they can
drag out into the light I've seen it
with my own two eyes second they're out
they'll just start melting and fusing
with the mask making it even bigger
adding another voice to the chorus and I
hate myself because every time I've seen
it happen all I can think is thank God
that's not me
God I wish I could do something to help
to save them but that's not the world we
live in the second they touch the light
it is already over I wouldn't be helping
anyone by adding My Flesh to one of
those things I don't want them using my
body to get to other people there's only
one thing I can do now keep moving at
night stay hidden get away from
population centers I've realized where I
need to go now I've still got a distant
memory of those broadcasts in the
earlier days of the event the SCP
Foundation I noted down coordinates to
the nearest facility they had on the
books and if I'm honest nearest is only
a relative term because at this rate
it's gonna take me an eternity to get
there but
will be worth it in the end when I get
there it'll all be worth it if I can at
least get some answers at least know why
the world turned into this hell those
SCP folks seem better prepared for this
than anyone so even if they can't fix
this they've at least got to have
answers right somebody needs to have
answers I really want to believe that
when the Sun goes down I'll start moving
again if you're watching this wish me
luck I don't have much food left on do
what I can yeah hey I realize I'm not
looking great right now but trust me you
should see the other guy day 65 today
86. never thought I would make it this
far but hey life's just full of
surprises before you ask him I mean why
would you ask it's not like I can hear
you it wasn't one of the monsters that
did this to me it was another person
just like me desperate hungry afraid the
one difference between me and them was
the fact that they had a handgun and I
didn't they asked for all the food I had
and when I wasn't exactly forthcoming
they decided to shoot me and steal the
last of my food while I lay bleeding on
the ground oh well okay that's not
entirely Fair they didn't leave me with
one protein bar which I had to cave and
eat a couple days ago since then I've
just been foraging with little food I
can from Plants along the way during my
nighttime walks but it isn't much and my
wound is giving me grief I sure hope
they've got doctors at this SCP
Foundation or otherwise
I may be even more out of luck than I
thought
here's the good news for you since I
know how much you love that I'm not far
off of the foundation site now even in
this state I'm probably only a couple
weeks away I think maybe I can will
myself to live that long at least
if I can get some answers just before I
die then I can be happy and sometimes
folks that's all you can ask for final
stretch let's hope I see you again on
the other end
I'm here I'm here the SCP Foundation on
day 100 but I don't understand where is
everybody hello is anybody there God
damn it why is nobody here I I don't
understand they're meant to have the
answers they were meant to know what was
going on here but they're all gone too
it isn't fair it isn't fair is this it
is it all just over the end of the
freaking world as we know it it isn't
fair it isn't fair
wait are those footsteps hello yes hello
I'm over here who's there oh my God what
the hell is that thing no no get away
from me oh God
disgusting
what is the most dangerous creature in
the universe here on planet Earth there
are creatures that have hardly evolved
since prehistoric eras like sharks
crocodiles and snakes perfect biological
killing machines but then again the
animal kingdom is nothing when compared
to the Menage array of creatures
contained by the SCP Foundation so once
again what is the most dangerous
creature in the universe is it scp-682
the damage regenerating reptile with a
hatred for all other forms of life or is
it the Scarlet king or is the broken God
more deserving of that title maybe the
answer still lies elsewhere and
thankfully there is one SCP in the
foundation's archives that might not be
the most dangerous itself but teaches us
a very important lesson about what the
most dangerous entity truly is this is
the story of
scp-001 the Spiral path an important
distinction before we go any further
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies
contained by the SCP Foundation it is
unclear why there are multiple files
collected under the shared designation
of scp-001 some believe these anomalies
are some of the earliest ever contained
by the foundation encountered before
they introduce their current numbering
system there is also the theory that
this is intentional misdirection that
the multiple scp-001 files are an
attempt by the foundation to conceal
secret information about the true
scp-001 anomaly sharing the name as
cp001 include the infamous
aforementioned Scarlet King a powerful
Eldritch being intent on ending all
creation another anomalous being with
similar levels of destructive power is
the gate Guardian believed to be an
angel standing at the entrance to the
Garden of Eden it too goes by the name
scp-001 but for the the purposes of this
video we will be using scp-001 to refer
to something otherwise codenamed the
spiral path and while it is not a
creature in and of itself
scp-001 does yield one answer to that
important question what is the most
dangerous creature in the universe on
paper scp-001 does not seem to be much
and it certainly doesn't appear to be
any sort of threat as its nickname
suggests the spiral path is exactly that
located deep in a wooded area known only
as site zero
scp-001 is a gravel path in the shape of
a spiral your first thought at hearing
that might be what could be so important
about a path if someone were to find
themselves walking along the spiral path
traveling clockwise around the gravel
then they will find that nothing happens
it's just a normal path with slight
inclines and declines as one traverses
it if one should walk counterclock
clockwise around it though then they
will begin to experience as cp001's
first anomalous effect the path will
begin to feel as if it is sloping uphill
getting steeper and steeper when they
reach the beginning of the path again a
person will still feel as if they are
walking endlessly uphill all the while
the path itself does not move or change
in form or altitude to put it simply
walking one way around
scp-001 causes it to behave normally
walking the other the path does not
adhere to the laws of physics you may
well be thinking is that all on a
surface level the spiral path does
appear to just be an unmoving low threat
anomaly while it may not be as
aggressive or malicious as some of the
SCP foundation's Rogues Gallery it is
still a spatial anomaly that defies all
euclidean geometry that might sound like
small potatoes when compared to
everything the SCP Foundation has faced
over the years but bear in mind if the
spiral path is truly as
scp-001 and the very first anomaly that
the foundation learned of then a simple
path that ignores the ordinary laws of
space and time would have been a major
Discovery in the organization's earliest
days but why would they still keep the
spiral path so heavily guarded all these
years later
scp-001 is kept behind a maximum
security fence that has been constructed
all the way around the perimeter of site
zero at all times the SCP Foundation
keeps no less than five fully armed
members of security Personnel on site to
keep watch over the spiral path and to
make sure that no one approaches it who
isn't authorized to there is a small
metal plaque too bearing an unknown
inscription on it special containment
procedures for scp-001 state that this
plaque is to be kept in good condition
and it should be immediately reported if
it shows any signs of damage a
foundation Physics laboratory is also
located nearby where research staff
tirelessly conducts scientific tests on
scp-001 and its anomalous properties so
there's definitely something more to the
spiral path than a simple stroll around
it would tell you attached to scp-001's
file is an item referred to as
document001-05 written by high-ranking
Foundation researcher Dr Everett Mann
any prospective or new members of the o5
council are required to read this
document and from the events it details
learn the truth not just about the truth
of the Spiral path but the truth about
the SCP Foundation itself Dr Mann begins
this file by explaining to the reader
that either he or one of the original
founders of the SCP Foundation must have
died and the person reading has been
appointed as a successor whether his
death was caused by an SCP an operative
from another anomalous organization like
the global occult Coalition or getting a
little close to the flame man states
that old age definitely wouldn't be what
killed him he writes we took care of
that and way whether he means that he
and the rest of the Old Guard are
somehow Immortal or just working for the
foundation would likely mean dying
before reaching old age is unclear but
Dr Mann's next statement is one that
changes the very way we view the
foundation and its entire purpose we
have never discovered an SCP in the
entire history of the foundation
according to document
001-05 every instance of an anomalous
creature entity or object is entirely
staged he then goes on to describe Aaron
Siegel A Gifted physicist that Dr Mann
regarded very highly I believe his name
would be there with Edison Einstein and
Hawking I knew him very well he was and
may still be my brother the pair
evidently shared a close personal
connection and it was Siegel who first
discovered
scp-001 during a hike Aaron stumbled
upon the spiral path noticing that no
matter how far uphill he seemed to
travel his elevation never once changed
only for him to end up back at the start
of the path being a physicist Siegel
quickly realized how this unassuming
gravel path did not conform to euclidean
Geometry that it did not fit within the
laws of nature constructing a small
wooden Shack nearby Aaron Siegel began
to study the properties of the Spiral
path the equation after equation hours
spent examining every variable and
experimenting with his findings until
something unforeseen happened Aaron
created an SCP a key that had the innate
ability to open any lock nowadays that
same key is still in The foundation's
Possession under the designation
scp-005 slowly Aaron began to bring
others into the fold trusted colleagues
and other scientific Minds among them
was of course Dr Everett Mann who was
still a medical student at Harvard at
the time this Brain Trust a think tank
composed of only a select few they were
the very beginning the the ones who
founded the SCP Foundation using their
own fortunes and funding from Thomas
Carter the group continued with Siegel's
experiments the scientists had high
hopes for what they could achieve
planning to change the world for the
better feeding the hungry providing
shelter to the homeless curing the sick
and even cheating death itself in the
beginning this Proto Foundation started
small their goals were Noble but could
not realistically be achieved overnight
they try to make items that would
improve life such as the Fountain of
Youth a partially sentient Civil War
statue and an extremely bouncy ball
better known to the foundation today as
scp-006
scp-011 and scp-018 respectively but
then this New Foundation began to grow
with more organization and a secret
facility and with that expansion came
emboldened scientists eager to change
the world the group began working on
human test subjects volunteers and
Drifters that soon became scps the
spiral path was not just a break in the
fabric of reality in a metaphorical
sense it referred to the spiraling path
the newly formed Foundation itself was
on every Discovery they made led to
another and that to another still until
things started to go wrong during the
continuing experiments Dr Mann created
scp-008 a deadly Zombie Plague capable
of infecting anyone with 100 percent
lethality more and more of the founders
were so invested in their projects that
the results were often nightmarish the
foundation needed help that came when
Thomas Carter showed their work to the
military in exchange for additional
funding and Personnel the SCP Foundation
expanded even further becoming an
international organization and bringing
in new researchers and staff in some
instances the founders would arrange for
the anomalies they had created to be
found by the new recruits other times
they would fabric reports changing the
details about things like scp-008 or the
Fountain of Youth were first discovered
anything the founders said was simply
now a fact no one questioned them even
then problems still arose founding
members broke away from the SCP
Foundation some even creating Splinter
groups that would later become infamous
groups of Interest the foundation's
directive shifted now focusing on the
containment of anomalies as yet more
were created through darker means
scp-231 was taken from an orphanage Dr
Mann himself vivisected a small boy who
then became scp-610 the flesh that hates
and there were more still able the blood
Pond and even the hard to destroy
reptile all of them were the creation of
the foundation itself but through it all
Dr Mann wrote he was never afraid of the
path that the foundation was on he was
never even afraid of all the monsters
and Abominations that he and the other
Founders had secretly created by
studying
scp-001 what truly scared him were the
anomalies the foundation didn't create
there were some that would just appear
in containment one day even if they
hadn't been there before they would seem
like they had always been there Dr man
closes document 001-05 with the
realization that he and the other
Founders simply were not in control
anymore the tale of Dr Mann and the
other founders of the SCP Foundation is
one of noble intentions that ultimately
became corrupted at first the founders
created scps that they hoped would
benefit Humanity but then came the
mistakes the accidents the monsters like
scp-008
scp-610 and even
scp-682 the foundation lied to the
governments and militaries of the world
claiming they'd found these scps not
created them and in return they received
funding and staff to expand allowing the
SCP Foundation to grow to become what it
is today Dr Mann posits that at this
point the foundation was no longer in
control but perhaps they never were and
all of this stems back from One Singular
starting point the spiral path it might
be impossible to truly know how many
anomalies and scps the foundation
created just from researching
scp-001 only the o5 council will ever
know exactly how many of the founders
discoveries they themselves were
responsible for and now you know the
answer to what's the most dangerous
creature in the universe it's Regular
People dabbling was something they could
never hope to fully understand starting
with the hope to change the world only
to create monsters that might one day
destroy it the military helicopters
sailed through the skies at a steady
Pace its destination somewhere in
Southwest Asia along one of the many
points where the legendary Euphrates and
Tigris Rivers meet depending on the
outcome this mission may have changed
the course of the SCP Foundation and its
activities forever or it might do
nothing at all such was often the way
when it came to dealing with the
unpredictable and the anomalous inside
the helicopter Dr Anton zarkov was
practically rattling with nervous
excitement ever since he'd been assigned
to the 682 termination detail after
years of wasting away in an archival
desk job he'd seen the kind of anomalies
you wouldn't believe 173 that
nightmarish statue that snaps the necks
of anyone who dared to look away from it
8 11 the strange and also strangely
adorable swamp woman whose caustic mucus
could reliably melt seemingly any
organic matter save of course 682 itself
and Dr zarkov was particularly
astonished by the aftermath of the epic
battle between 096 and xav2 which left
both of these indestructible monsters
horribly maimed but all of that it was
nothing compared to what they were going
to witness today Dr zarkov muttered a
prayer to himself in frightened
reverence Dr Cliff who was sitting
across from him in the helicopter wasn't
quite as wound up like some action movie
cliche made manifest he sliced chunks
from a plump red apple with a Bowie
knife and sucked the pieces off the
blade clef found zarkov's nervousness
little more than amusing first time
inside zero rookie clef asked between
apple slices Dr zarkov nodded forcing a
Meek smile clef just chuckled
uh you're wasting your time you know
Clough said everyone takes a shot at the
reptile I face it down myself once mono
imano and during that moment I realized
something as much as it pains me to ever
throw in the towel We're not gonna kill
this thing it's just a budget sink of
course these kinds of doubts had cross
Dr zarkov's mind before he'd watch
countless termination attempts organized
by far more senior researchers than
himself fail and fail embarrassingly
something about signing your name up for
682 termination was like tying on a
blindfold grabbing a bat and stepping up
to a pinata except in this case the
pinata isn't wearing a blindfold and
somehow it can hit you back it is a
one-way ticket to professional
humiliation and if you're unlucky enough
to get too close when things go south it
can be so much worse Dr zarkov well and
truly believe that he would be the
exception to so much miserable failure
after all this was an idea no
had tried before an announcement over
the intercom signaled that they had now
entered site-0 airspace they'd be
landing shortly and just like that Dr
zarkov was all raised hairs and Goose
flesh once again it seemed like such a
hazy distant miracle that his project
proposal would even get majority
approval from the o5 council and now he
was about to touch down and actually see
it naturally Dr clef noticed Dr zarkov's
emotional cues and like so many
playground bullies decided to seize on
it don't buy into the hype Dr Clough
said it's really not that special the
helicopter touched down Dr zarkov felt
defensive he was almost tempted to use
hard words but he realized from Dr
clef's mischievous smile that perhaps
that was always the intention he
certainly had a reputation if one were
to put it in the most neutral terms
possible but this was your 001 proposal
Dr Cliff zarkov countered I would have
thought you'd be more invested in this
Dr klaff Rose to his feet and sheathed
his Bowie knife as the helicopter's side
door opened he gestured for Dr zarkov to
get up and follow him before saying
believe me even a giant flaming demigod
loses its luster when you need to write
enough of those stupid reports on it the
two researchers disembarked from the
helicopter and walked into the legendary
containment facility site zero one of
the most important and secretive
containment sites out there even by the
standards of the ever clandestine SCP
Foundation if ever containment
procedures failed here they'd be staring
down the barrel of an unprecedented
situation A Patmos XK Class end of the
world scenario after all they were
dealing with one of the most serious and
Powerful anomalies they'd ever contained
here cliff and zarkov entered the
control room filled with huge monitors
displaying every kind of recordable
metric but the largest screens were
dominated by long-range Drone footage of
the iconic anomaly they were all there
to see
scp-001 perhaps better known as Uriel
the gate Guardian while Dr clef remained
unfazed Dr zarkov felt a single tear
crawling down his cheek he had never
seen an entity so utterly awe-inspiring
an impossibly tall glowing humanoid
entity with eight great fiery wings and
a glowing blade made of pure Heavenly
Fire every bit as hot as the sun to
think that such an incredible creature
existed on the same Earth as him made
him feel so incredibly small the
theories as to the creature's true
nature were as Myriad as they were
unknowable some of the more devout among
the foundation's ranks even believe that
he is a direct servant of the abrahamic
god guarding the gate to Paradise the
Garden of Eden Heaven itself Dr klaff
just laughed everything you'd hope it'd
be zarkov he said Dr zarkov nodded more
Dr clef and more even from such a
distance the raw power of the gate
Guardian is impossible to ignore it
radiates off of the being like an
invisible Aura Dr zarkov had read all
the files to get within a kilometer of
the mighty entity would be to court
death anyone who approached it would
taste the heat of its sword cleave them
apart at the atomic level and
effectively erasing them from existence
it's about as dead as anyone could
possibly be save for someone being
thrown into scp-3930 and literally
removed from the plane of existence
scp-3930 had failed to annihilate the
hard to destroy reptile but perhaps
where that whole lot of nothing had
failed the gate Guardian would succeed
to remain floating fixed on one place as
though waiting for something but what
perhaps a fateful confrontation with a
certain reptilian nightmare Dr zarkov
hoped like many he had heard the most
famous story involving scp-001 the gate
Guardian which took place before even
the days of the SCP Foundation after all
every Foundation needs a Founder doesn't
it and that's how it began the founder
was a mysterious figure no matter who
you ask some say it was 05-1 others say
it was the legendary administrator some
even believe that it was someone else
someone older someone who predated even
the current o5 Council and administrator
a wise and learned figure going on a
pilgrimage around the Known World in
hopes of expanding their perspective and
seeking out the strange and unusual he
was traveling down the river Tigress
that the founder encountered the gate
guardian of course as always from a mile
away the founder saw the distant glowing
Point shaped like a human being with
wings it was unlike anything they'd ever
born witness to that's when the founder
felt a door open in the back of their
mind and something sneak in a single
word projecting somehow infinite
Authority remember
the very presence of the word made the
Founder's body rattle never had they
heard such a voice conveying such
certainty and power it had to be the
voice of the distant glowing figure it
could be anything else could it much
like Dr zarkov would experience hundreds
of years later the founder even as a
person so powerful knowledgeable and
influential suddenly felt so
unimaginably small the founder became
aware of not just the extent of the
world around them or even the universe
but a terrifying Multiverse of
possibilities there was light out there
of course but even more darkness and
terrifying things were hiding in the
dark is that what prepare meant did it
mean to be ready for all the Terrible
Things hiding in the dark just waiting
for the opportunity to strike just how
great was the extent of the things
Humanity didn't understand out there the
Founder's mind was flooded with so many
possibilities if there was a tide of
monsters in the Blackness that needed to
be fought back it was too much for any
one person to ever handle the founder
needed a group all gathered around the
same mission to contain the coming
threat that the great glowing being had
warned them about people of focus
commitment and sheer willpower people
who would accept the knowledge of the
Terrible Things in the darkness and
still not waver in the face of their
great and Noble challenge people who if
necessary would be willing to die in the
dark so that the rest of the human race
would live in the light they would be
Humanity's greatest Defenders even
though they would defend in secret this
was how it had all begun supposedly Dr
zarkov had heard the story whispered
many times while conducting his research
into
scp-001 and now here he stood perhaps
where the founder hadn't been standing
all those years ago the SCP Foundation
had faced down greater threats than
scp-682
the hanged King the sealed King The
Scarlet King hell if they wanted to they
could go toe-to-toe with the Burger King
and all of that had begun with a single
word from the mighty gate Guardian
surely an ornery overgrown lizard
wouldn't be too much for it to handle
but of course they hadn't just come here
to look at the gate Guardian that'd be
an egregious waste of time and
helicopter fuel they'd come here
transporting Precious Cargo a chunk of
scp-682's Flesh cut from the Beast
itself currently it was attached to yet
another remote controlled drone set on a
collision course for the gate Guardian
Dr zarkov watched the video feeds with
sweaty Palms as he saw the Drone and its
diabolical cargo enter the video's View
getting closer to the gate Guardian by
the moment Closer Closer until the gate
Guardian struck out with its great and
terrible sword for such an
astronomically huge being to move so
incredibly fast was astounding in and of
itself but what Dr zarkov found even
more exciting was the result in one
quick slash of its solar blade both the
Drone and the scp-682 tissue sample were
utterly evaporated gone reduced to less
than even Ash Dr zarkov's face split
into a mannequin if it could destroy the
tissue sample then surely it could
destroy the monster itself and what a
glorious day that would be meanwhile
back at the cross-testing chambers of
site 19
scp-682 was having another miserable day
it was dragged half melted out of its
acid tank at 3am in the morning and left
slowly regenerating on the floor a
typical SCP Foundation wake-up call it
thought to itself with the role of its
still regenerating eyes what form of
horrible torment would be in store for
it this time it began scrolling through
its mental Rolodex for the most recent
failed but painful termination attempts
oh yes of course they tried Suffocation
via vacuum that definitely made scp-682
feel a little light-headed at least
until of course it adapted its body to
begin releasing a gas of similar
composition to its native atmosphere
which had certainly given those
white-coated wearing sadists a lot to
take note about then how could it forget
they tried roasting it to death with
extremely high temperatures thankfully
as always it had a trick up its sleeve
adapting a carapace made of solid helium
to defend it from the fire then
shattering it to shred a bunch of those
buffoons in the orange jumpsuits then
they'd cut off a sample of its flesh
shoved it into some absurd industrial
blender before shoving what's left into
a centrifuge what a Divine pleasure it
had been for 682 to hear the explosion
down the hall when the antimatter
embedded in its genes went off and put a
number of those idiotic Foundation
drones in the hospital for months serves
them right to continually meddling in
the matters of forces they couldn't even
hope to understand and today they were
feeding at the carcass of a dead cow
scp-682 side it felt sometimes that the
dolt's testing it had forgotten the note
reading highly intelligent on its file
being dragged into one of those ghastly
Chambers and given some form of Novel
stimulus could only mean one thing
something stupid and painful was going
to happen said stupid painful thing in
this case was that the cow was spiked
with an instance of
scp-3521 also known as the banana Pill
by datto what followed was a remarkably
absurd instance even by scp-682
cross-test standards where a huge number
of bananas spontaneously burst out of
682's body being a big fan of bananas
apparently 682 was actually able to eat
and metabolize the bananas faster than
the anomalous banana Pill by dotto could
produce them and because bananas are
each individually slightly radioactive
682 was able to synthesize this
Collective radiation into a powerful
death ray that it used to cause a great
deal of death and destruction as far as
Dr zarkov and the rest of the SCP
Foundation were concerned this thing
being cleaved apart on an atomic level
by the gate Guardian couldn't come soon
enough sometimes it took the ultimate
night to slay the Ultimate Dragon not
long after that
scp-682 was dosed up on enough sedatives
to give New York City a week-long nap
and carted over to site zero on a
heavily secured armored Convoy taking
scp-682 this far between containment
sites was considered a matter of grave
seriousness in other words the result of
this little experiment better have been
good to justify the insane security risk
it took to even get the damn lizard out
here Dr zarkov and Dr clef decided to
co-supervise the cross-test from the
safety of these site-0 observation deck
either would have been foolish to want
to get any closer even Dr klev while
undeniably a loose cannon didn't have an
outright Death Wish among us of course
wishing death on scp-682 would count
682's sedated body was strapped to a
large unmanned vehicle the kind they
might use for an exploratory mission on
another planet and sent in the direction
of the gate guardian's deadly proximal
Zone a secondary camera drone was also
sent in to lag behind correctly
predicting that when the gate Guardian
Struck scp-682 it would obliterate the
unmanned vehicle too and whatever
happened out there the foundation needed
it on camera Dr zarkov had sweaty palms
and gritted teeth seeing the culmination
of his professional career unfold in
front of him Dr clef was looking at a
meme on his phone as 682 got closer it
began hearing a booming voice in its
head just like the founder had so long
ago the voice simply said one word over
and over getting louder as the unmanned
vehicle brought the two Titans closer
and closer and closer
good
682 still feeling groggy thought oh if
it only were so simple and then it
happened
scp-682 entered the dreaded one
kilometer range the guardian slashed
down with its mighty sword creating a
brilliant flash of light in the
aftermath the unmanned vehicle was
obliterated and 682 was left heavily
injured on the ground still trying to
process what had just happened 682
looked up sobered by the pain and saw
the being that had dealt this blow 682
began to sneer is this meant to be the
garden it said before breaking into a
venomous laugh
this is not the garden the garden is far
west of here the gate Guardian struck
again with its flaming blade once again
projecting that single word
When the Smoke cleared 682 was even more
horrifically injured with only one limb
left but still Against All Odds alive it
used the one limb to drag itself towards
the gate Guardian fueled by pure rage
and spite die you command me to die oh
what do we all like that but
my curse for suggesting the fruit the
reptile ground back at the base Dr
zarkov was mortified how could it
possibly be surviving all this the sword
was meant to cleave apart its victims on
an atomic level Atomic since freaking
Adams God damn it Dr zarkov was she had
a paper bag to breathe into Dr klaff
showing an uncharacteristic degree of
compassion padded zarkov on the back
saying it's okay buddy we all remember
our first time back at the center of the
action the gate Guardian blasted 682
with its solar blade again somehow
despite the terrifying Power Wheel did
by the guardian 682 continued to live it
was alive barely but after three strikes
from The Sword to be alive with whatever
the evil version of a miracle would be
this is not the garden and you are not
Uriel 682 roared before spitting at the
gate Guardian Pretender one more more
violent strike from the gate guardian
and six City two finally collapsed
unconscious from the extent of its pain
and its injuries but despite all of Dr
zarkov's hopes the gate Guardian did not
strike a killing blow on the unconscious
Beast instead it transmitted another
word another order impossible for any
human being to ignore
[Music]
as though in a trance the workers of
site zero including Dr zarkov and Dr
clef entered the Forbidden one kilometer
exclusion Zone the gate Guardian allowed
them safe passage as they used tools and
vehicles to pick up the heavily injured
scp-682 and carted away from the gate
guardian's feet after they all came back
to their senses Dr zarkov simply said
what just happened Dr clef just Shrugged
I've learned to stop questioning it say
kids would you like to hear a story
cause we've got a really good one for
you seriously you're going to love it
it's a classic rags to Rich's tale about
one man's rise from humble beginnings to
become one of History's Greatest and
most Visionary toy makers or maybe it
isn't maybe it's about a company that
literally came from nothing whose
Origins are still shrouded in mystery
maybe it's about a woman breaking the
glass ceiling to take over the toy
company left to her by her ex Centric
father maybe it's about all of these
things but the one thing we can tell you
about the story of Dr wondertainment is
that every word of it is true or at
least as far as anything is true in the
weird wonderful world of the SCP
Foundation as long as you believe will
all have a wonderful time as long as you
believe nothing can hurt you not in the
fabulous world of doctor wondertainment
Dr wondertainment is the name given to
scp-001 who due to his relatively benign
Nature has been classified as safe by
the foundation rather than focusing on
containing wondertainment himself the
SCP Foundation has centered its efforts
on containing the products that he
creates he is a Class 1 reality warper
capable of constructing otherwise normal
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and eventually
dangerous toys and games that are
distributed by as yet unknown means many
of wondertainment's toys are in The
foundation's Possession such as scp-445
origami paper that takes on properties
of whatever it's folded to look like and
scp-3147 lollipops that allow people to
switch voices with each other doctor
wondertainment was born into a family of
humble means his mother was a seamstress
and his father was an accountant
unsatisfied with his mundane life
wondertainment's only joy growing up was
in the stories that his father would
tell him about an ancestor of his who
was once a famous toy maker inspired by
these stories wondertainment developed
an interest in crafting toys and as an
adult set out to learn the secrets he
would need to create toys unlike
anything the world had ever seen he
spent his life following rumors of
magical artifacts and Enchanted trinkets
until his search brought him to a
mysterious Factory if you've seen our
previous videos on scp-001 proposals you
can probably guess that this Factory was
the Factory The Mysterious place where
new scps are supposedly created
wondertainment barely escaped the
massacre and the foundation takeover of
the factory with his life but he was
able to find a variety of notes that he
took with him these notes contained
clues that led him to the workshop of
his famous toymaker ancestor and from
there he reclaimed his Birthright that
was the day that he truly became Dr
wondertainment it's a fun story isn't it
very straightforward but perhaps it is a
little underwhelming for an scp-001
proposal after all scp-001 is the
collective designation given to some of
the most important anomalies of all time
including many that could have
potentially been involved in the
foundation's very founding hmm let's
start again Reginald filbert Lionel
Archibald Westinghouse entertainment III
is the name given to
scp-001 who due to his highly
unpredictable Nature has been classed as
Euclid by the foundation and he is to be
detained as soon as his location can be
ascertained until he can be captured the
SCP Foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that he
creates he is a Class 2 reality warper
capable of constructing otherwise normal
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially dangerous toys
games candy soft drinks and other
products aimed at children and young
teens these products are distributed by
as yet unknown means many of
wondertayman's Creations are in
Foundation possession such as the often
imitated but never matched little
mister's collection which are a group of
living collect with unique anomalous
properties due to entertainment's
reality warping abilities it is
impossible to pin down concrete
information about his history what we
can tell you for sure is that he's
Immortal and ageless and comes from a
long line of wondertainment stretching
all the way back to the Cretaceous
Period where they made all sorts of toys
for the good little dinosaur children
it's also widely known that he is in
fact not a real person but merely the
manifestation of the dreams of every
child on Earth brought forth solely by
the power of imagination no confirmed
sightings of Dr wondertainment have ever
occurred but Witnesses have described
him as dashing very handsome for his age
and a lovely chap capable of creating
Whimsy and wonder with the snap of his
fingers he's a tall man about the height
of a piece of string and he's
immediately recognizable by his walking
stick and w-shaped mustache it's also
been reported that he has scarring
around the circumference of both
almost as if his hands have been removed
and reattached at some point however the
truth of the matter is that hmm no no
we're telling it all wrong again this
doesn't do anything to capture the scope
of the wondertainment story it needs to
feel bigger more comprehensive let's try
it again Dr wondertainment is a
trademark of the wondertainment toy
company the name given to
scp-001 a corporation that due to its
consistent output of anomalous items is
classed by the foundation as ketter
until this company can be permanently
shut down the SCP Foundation has focused
its efforts on containing the products
that it creates the collective power of
the company's constituent employees and
the technology they make use are
equivalent to that of a class 3 reality
warper the one detainment company
produces and sells a range of products
ranging from the seemingly normal to the
downright weird all imbued with
anomalous property days the company has
become infamous for their constant
output of bizarre magical and
potentially dangerous toys games candy
soft drinks and other products aimed at
children teens and young at heart adults
these products are made and distributed
from Wonder World trademark a location
that is yet unknown to the foundation
but offers factory tours every hour from
Tuesday to Friday many of
wondertainment's Creations are in
Foundation possession such as
wondertainment's famous Dragon snails
the real fire-breathing pet you can keep
in your pocket not much is known about
the inner workings of the wondertainment
company the SCP Foundation has no
information currently on the company's
leadership structure location history or
corporate policies various former and
current employees have been interviewed
regarding their experiences working for
wondertainment but they never seem to be
able to remember very much of use those
interviewed variously describe the
wondertainment company as a regular
office building an immense Toy Factory
an amusement park but all agree it's the
best place they ever worked in fact you
should apply for a job there we I mean
they have a few openings in their legal
department or so I've heard oh silly me
it seems we've gotten off topic you're
here to hear about the scp-001 proposal
posting a job ad wasn't what I meant to
do when I hacked into
I mean well don't worry about that
forget I said a thing now let's try this
again but this time we'll add a Twist
Isabel Helga Anastasia Parvati
wondertainment V is the name given to
scp-001 who due to her ability to spread
sunshine and Whimsy wherever she goes
has been classed as thomyal by the
foundation and due to her immensely
unpredictable nature the SCP Foundation
has resolved to just leave her be
because she can't be captured the SCP
Foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that she creates
she is a class 4 reality warper capable
of constructing wonderful Funtastic
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties she's famous and widely
beloved for using this ability to create
bizarre magical and not even a little
bit dangerous toys games candy soft
drinks and other products aimed at
everyone from ages 9 to 99. these
products are distributed by as yet
unknown means many of wondertainment's
Creations are in Foundation possession
such as
scp-3551 the awesome inflatable Alien
Invaders and
scp-2514 a lovely horse who can sing
Happy Birthday
how grab one detainment inherited the
wondertainment name from her father who
either passed away or never existed at
all the circumstances of his death and
perhaps non-existence were very messy
involving a mass murderer the leader of
a shadowy international extra
governmental paramilitary organization
at least one deity and four bent
paperclips she owns Six corgis and all
of them are named Jeremy in a free time
she likes to
no no this is all still wrong all right
enough is enough you want to know who Dr
wondertainment really is well you asked
for it Dr wondertainment is the name
given to
scp-001 who due to his deity level power
has been classed as a pollyon by the
foundation there is no possible way to
contain him he is a Class 5 reality
warper capable of breaking down and
reconstructing the very laws of reality
did you really think that those little
trinkets were the full extent of my I
mean his Creations did you truly think
of him as such a small Petty creature
doctor wondertainment is no mere toy
Smith no he is a god want examples of
his Creations just look around you
everything from the most innocent safe
class to the most harrowing ketter class
it's all thanks to him
behind everything Marshall Carter and
dark the sarkists the Church of the
broken God even the Scarlet King himself
all that time all that effort all it
came down to was one entity One Singular
living personification of chaos one day
the SCP Foundation will finally give up
trying to find out how he distributes
his products when they will finally see
how small and worthless their attempts
to restore order really are and they
will be driven before his power they
will crumble and Decay into nothingness
you will bow before doctor
wondertainment
huh
[Laughter]
had you going for a second there didn't
we you should have seen the looks on
your faces but let's start again one
more time we're being serious this time
mask off here's the true story of Dr
wondertainment Dr wondertainment is the
name given to
scp-001 who due to his relatively benign
Nature has been classed as neutralized
by the foundation rather than focusing
on containing wondertainment himself the
SCP Foundation has focused its efforts
on containing the products that he
creates he is a reality warper whose
limits have yet to be documented capable
of constructing otherwise normal objects
and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially dangerous toys
and games that are distributed by as yet
unknown means due to his secretive
nature almost nothing is known of Dr
wondertainment's true Origins and the
waters have been muddied extensively by
the side effects of his reality warping
ability in fact it's entirely possible
that Dr wondertain himself doesn't know
who he is anymore it's possible that all
the proposed Origins and descriptions of
Dr wondertainment are true in their own
way but it is equally possible that none
of them are all that's known for sure is
that Dr wondertainment be they male or
female Corporation or single individual
is a constant thorn in the SCP
foundation's side no matter who they
really are they're not going away soon
and only time will tell who they'll be
tomorrow or what further Horrors they in
their company will create and that's
where our story will have to come to an
end at least for now we hope you enjoyed
it and remember keep believing hour one
there is only one news story on every
website newspaper and TV screen the
flowers are blooming everywhere all
across the globe every country every
land mass the bitter cold of the
Antarctic gives way to a glowing rainbow
of petals the Sahara Desert and Death
Valley become beacons of thriving
Technicolor plant life the highest
mountains the lowest valleys the darkest
caves the flowers even burst free from
the concrete of cities as if reminding
us that really it was never our world we
were only borrowing it and today our
lease is up this is
scp-001 object class unnecessary it was
foretold by Tales from other dimensions
a distant future coming down the tracks
towards us and today the train has
reached the station nobody's reporting
on how the economy or the stock market
is doing today no point celebrity
scandals have faded away into
nothingness greedy businessmen lying
politicians brutal tyrants none of them
are making the headlines today the very
last headlines the world gone beautiful
and what a shame it takes the end of it
all to make us realize what really
matters to us that's right you're
looking at the end of the world but it's
okay don't panic take a deep breath in
and out it was bound to happen
eventually so no point worrying now even
the foundation knows that this just
isn't something they can stop so instead
of asking things like how can we prevent
this or do we have any final Tricks Up
Our Sleeve let's ask a different
question entirely what would you do if
you knew that you only had 24 hours
until all life on Earth ends think hard
after all even if you never live to see
the flowers bloom a final day will still
come for you just as it does for us all
hours six a d-class sits alone in the
cell when he sees the flowers growing
out of the ground normally he'd assumed
that this meant he was in some kind of
foundation experiment but not today
everyone on Earth had an innate sense
that the time is now a kind of gallows
calm spreads out over everyone and
everything it's over and that's okay we
all knew it was going to happen
eventually right he Sighs and gives a
slight smile those flowers sure are
beautiful that's when he hears footsteps
outside his cell approaching a key
slides into his cell door and opens
there stands Dr gears holding a bottle
of wine and two glasses anyone who knows
him might think he's been replaced by
some kind of shape-shifting anomaly or
had his mind taken over by a powerful
Cognito Hazard but no it's him the
famously called Dr Charles Ogden gears
Dr gear says come on it's a lovely day
out there it'd be a terrible waste to
spend the whole thing cooped up in here
it'd feel like a trick on any day but
this the d-class nods and follows the
doctor out the normally oh so stoic
Foundation senior researcher force
himself in the d-class each a glass of
wine and asks What's Your Name by the
way I don't think I ever checked the
d-class replies that his name is Harold
the two smile and shout as they exit the
now empty d-class containment Wing
everyone else is outside already
researchers guards administrative staff
and d-classes all rubbing elbows
enjoying the beautiful sun on their last
day together Elsewhere on site a flock
of scp-514 is released just as identical
flocks are being released from every
containment site all over the world
they've prepared it all for this very
day
scp-514 is a special breed of homing
pigeons created by the Mana charitable
Foundation which have the power to
suppress aggression for those within
their field of anomalous influence and
now millions of them are flying all over
the world after all there's no point
fighting on a day like this there is no
future left to secure people always told
them there would forever be hope until
the flowers bloomed no situation was
ever truly over until the World Went
beautiful but in the absence of Hope
there was something even more inviting
total absolute calm the site-19
Personnel sit together and watch the
flowers bloom hour 12 all militaries
call a global ceasefire soldiers from
opposing sides hug and shake hands in
Flowery fields that once seemed choked
by death and blood borders fade bitter
rivalries turn to dust Korea unifies all
is quiet in the Middle East gangsters
and drug cartels dropped their weapons
and return home to their families and
friends as flocks of scp-514 Fly Above
what good is all the blood money in the
world on a day like this wardens walk
cell to cell through all the world's
prisons granting people their freedom
again sometimes after lifetimes of not
having it they taste the air again feel
the sun on their face they close their
eyes drink it in and walk among the
flowers free men locations of Marshall
Carter and dark limited close their
doors and shudder their Windows
worldwide for the first time in as long
as any of them can remember they turn
their signs to closed they've earned a
day off everyone has the chaos
Insurgency rolls up their plans and
burns them they drop their weapons and
throw away their tactical gear as they
do so they can't help but question
themselves what was it all for in the
end what was any of it for all the
fighting and bloodshed and death we did
it day after day only to do it again the
next day what silly reasons we killed
and died for what's silly reasons indeed
the global occult Coalition dismisses
its staff thanking them for their
service and telling them to go spend
their last hours with the ones they love
like the foundation they accept that
this is the one true Final End no ritual
to stop no monster to fight no evil
extra dimensional entity to thwart just
go outside and smell the flowers while
you still can the Serpent's hand are
similar they decide after decades
fighting a losing battle they'll spend
their last day in The Wanderers library
reading some of their favorite volumes
all these wonderful stories now left for
other Earths to read their own stories
would be counted among them in the end
and they take great comfort in that in a
sense everyone will live forever in the
pages of the books in The Wanderers
Library Hermann Fuller's circus of the
disquieting releases all of its Freaks
and clowns from their Twisted grasp to
go and live out whatever small dreams
and tiny Pleasures they could find over
their last hours they have no Foundation
of fear anymore nobody Minds their
strange appearances and odd behaviors
why would anyone waste such a beautiful
day judging others on the last day on
Earth there's nothing left to prove
sarcasists dropped their ancient
flesh-bound tomes and acolytes of the
broken God put down their gilded blades
on the slopes of Siberia the jungles of
Peru and the most isolated beaches of
Mexico Twisted flesh finally touched
living metal in the spirit of husbandry
their Eternal war is at its end in the
face of the blooming World they didn't
seem so different after all the Agents
of the doctor wondertainment Corporation
predictably chose to spend their last
hours sitting around and playing with
toys together time well spent if you ask
us in a highly secretive location
perhaps the most heavily secured place
in the entire world the 13 members of
the legendary o5 Council decide to just
sit and talk anyone who knows anything
about this secretive cabal can tell you
the o5 council has spent a considerable
portion of their very very long lives
trying to figure out ways to dodge and
cheat death but now facing a death they
can't Dodge the same calm washing over
the rest of the world has finally
reached them too all they can really
think this time is well played reaper
well played as they chat about the kind
of inane casual things that they haven't
had time to discuss in years 05-3
suggests inviting the Ethics Committee
over to join nobody disagrees hour 16.
it isn't just the d-classes all Sapient
and non-aggressive scps have been
released from containment free to spend
the last of their time as they wish tens
of thousands of anomalous individuals
are released from containment sites all
over the globe it'd be the greatest
victory that the Serpent's hand could
ever ask for if they weren't all too
busy reading to notice
scp-105 Iris Thompson finally returns to
her parents the foundation had fed them
the lie that their daughter had died
many years before but as Iris had a
tendency to do she was ready to work a
miracle her parents Embrace her with
open arms they'll spend their last hours
together catching up on what's happened
since they parted ways and making up for
lost time they couldn't be happier
scp-1867 Lord Blackwood the Fantastical
sea snail is delivered into a warm Rock
pool near the site where he was being
contained there he might finally have
one more Grand Adventure before all is
said and done though afterward he may
not have the time to tell anyone about
it a terrible shame really because
nobody spins a yarn like Lord Blackwood
the non-aggressive little misters Run
free Mr Fish eagerly returns to his
native Boston Massachusetts where he
enjoys one more Lobster sandwich before
the end of the war World Mr headless
decides to go hat shopping because he
wants to look good for the apocalypse Mr
lost finally settles down for the
afternoon deciding that just this once
he's earned himself a rest
scp-2800 Cactus men returns to Edinburgh
to spend his last days picking up litter
and helping old ladies cross the street
scp-3663 the tunnel monster walks the
streets of his hometown searching for an
old friend hoping to reunite before it
all ends
scp-073 Kane decides to take a walk
outside for the first time in thousands
of years he can't help but Smile as the
bright colorful life beneath his feet is
growing faster than his presence can
kill it what a truly beautiful day
knowing that there's no longer time for
Colts to form and bother him
scp-2662 Cthulhu decides to take a break
from his intense Minecraft session and
go take a walk outside it feels so good
to have of the sun on his tentacles once
more and to feel the lush green grass
under his suction cups he shakes his
head thinking once again about the
irritating Cults that had been pestering
him for decades what kind of idiot would
want him to destroy a world like this
scp-343 also known as God size and looks
over all his creation for what he knows
to be the last time his mouth curls into
a smile as he thinks well we had a
pretty good run still in a Cell
scp-049 the plague doctor puts his feet
up and decides to relax the pestilence
will soon be taken care of on some
animalistic level below thought below
even Instinct
scp-096 feels grateful that no gaze will
ever fall upon it again somewhere
fizzling in a vat of acid within a
highly secure containment chamber
scp-682 is feeling for the first time in
its hellish existence a sense of
profound relief the pain the hate the
rage the constant termination attempts
it all be over soon hour 23 people
Gather in the streets they laugh and
dance and sing as the moon shines fat
and white far above deep in their hearts
they quietly contemplate the end of all
of this but why worry why spoil the fun
there's no future left to worry about
strangers become as close as family in
the end human or otherwise anomalous or
non-anomalous chaos Insurgency agents
have last suppers with ex-serpants hands
and GOC operatives there is no hate left
no violence No Malice no cruelty the
greatest tragedy in all of this is that
it took the ultimate end to bring it out
in people but why worry why worry
seconds pass then minutes the world
buzzes it hums trillions of creatures
doing everything they'd wanted even
though it won't last in the face of the
true end the world has never been more
alive hour 24 silence forever and ever
and ever good night we'll end this video
the way it began by putting a question
to you how would you spend your last 24
hours on Earth let us know down in the
comments because it'll happen to all of
us eventually they came from Beyond the
world from over the world from under the
world they came from inside the stars
and from behind the rain they came from
The Gnome lands and they came from the
secret places of old the vast ones who
drank of the nebulae the small ones who
did not care what happened beyond the
banks of their Rivers the ones who
bathed in the light and the ones who
watched from the Shadows the ones who
loved us and the ones who forgot about
us the ones who hate us now and the ones
who love us still the ones who sung with
the rats and the ones who swam with the
leviathans they came from far and near
they came one and all they came to end
the world as you may already know from
our previous video in this series a
mysterious being known only as the
harbinger unlocked scp-001 the lock and
brought about the omnipocalypse every
single World destroying XK class
scenario on the books from Foundation
files to the most ancient mythological
tomes and some we'd never even imagined
began to come true a world flooded with
terrifying anomalous activity from
unfurling Skies to Giant nightmarish
animals was about where we left off now
it's time to open your eyes and wake up
this is the kind of nightmare you can't
encounter while you're asleep
scp-5720 the astronomically inclined
crane went about out its daily work the
small mechanical crane always occupied
itself with the one task that gave its
existence any meaning arranging esoteric
model solar systems but something was
different today
scp-5720 put the final touches on its
latest model and then lifted its
mechanical arms skywards pointing
directly into the vast and Starry
Infinity above but were they Stars no
not today as scp-5720 looked up at the
sky this time the sky looked back they
weren't Stars they were eyes something
was coming towards Earth from the
furthest reaches of the outer dark an
armada of worldenders coming from above
below and all around a whole Cosmos of
supremely powerful beings zeroing in on
our pale blue dot a thought crossed
through whatever passed as the mind of
this strange little crane
[Music]
dimension
followed by another word ringing loud
and clear and holy as a mighty church
bell
and at that moment everything did
thousands of miles away a new God landed
on Earth appearing like a great wall of
dense matted fur descending from the sky
the mother of the ones that came before
after eons of absence she had eventually
returned to greet her children the true
rulers and stewards of this land but Ur
on um was surprised and horrified by
what she saw their great cities their
sprawling structures their beautiful art
and advanced culture all gone laid to
waste by the worthless hairless Apes
that once lurked in the forests with the
other animals something had happened
something had changed the humans had
slaughtered her people destroyed their
accomplishments tarnished their legacy
driven the few that were left out of
Their Kingdoms and into the forests
treated them as mere animals and built
their hideous concrete cities over their
bones and they had the gall to call them
Bigfoot or scp-1000 because thanks to
them their beautiful true name had been
lost to time she looked skywards and
cried out in Despair and anguish at the
loss of her children inconsolable but
then she felt something a glimmer of
hope in her mind the possibility that
things would change that the humans
would be toppled from their Thrones and
True Justice would be achieved she
called out to her remaining children and
her children answered across the globe
another great entity awoke deep
underneath a mountain when it stirred
into life and broke free it shattered
the entire Mountain on top of it as
easily as you or me displacing a bed
sheet it took to the skies massive but
unseeable to the human eye it soared
through the air gazing down upon the
world it hadn't seen for thousands of
years once it had feasted on the blood
sacrifices of human subjects hoping to
avoid its Wrath but humans weren't the
petty little group of huddled cavemen
that they had once been now they were in
their billions gathered in impossibly
large settlements The Entity sought to
find a seat of power that it could
influence but now it was spoiled for
Choice eventually it zeroed in and found
its perfect Target an SCP Foundation
containment site here it would find a
new form to take and more Petty pathetic
humans to bring under its Mighty thrall
it landed in
scp-765 the duck pod it is an anomalous
Pond that is you guessed it full of
ducks and initially induces feelings of
Serenity in its victims before later
inducing not so pleasant feelings when
the entity plummeted into the water it
began to absorb and bond with the
anomaly growing to Epic sizes as it
assumed a form that the minds of us
feeble humans could comprehend a giant
terrifying duck it released a mighty
earth-shaking quack as it plotted across
the Countryside to cause Mayhem
elsewhere in Europe more violent Madness
was unfolding a crimson rooster Cod then
a Golden Rooster and then a rooster of
soot red anyone with a basic knowledge
of Norse mythology was shaking in their
boots as a mighty Beast stirred in the
heart of a desolate cave the chains that
had once held the Monstrous dog in place
now broke it Rose and licked its Jagged
fangs excited to stain them with the
blood of its enemies it was the great
hound fenir omen of the end times here
to Herald the end of all things a
trumpet boomed across the globe with no
Apparent Source people in the streets in
New York Delhi London Cape Town and
countless other towns cities and hamlets
the world overpaused and listened in
confusion below them the great and
terrible Jordan the thought to be
mythological mid-guard serpent stirred
from its previously Eternal Slumber and
began to uncoil its body the shifting
caused earthquakes and tsunamis along
the coast of Greenland as towns and
Villages crumbled killing thousands
fenrir stalked along the length of
Denmark slaughtering and devouring
anyone or anything unlucky enough to
cross its path but it did not wage its
war against mankind alone behind it a
hellish Army of burning Giants marched
Mighty hands clutching molten weapons
Ragnarok was upon us now Odin save us
all and the administrator slept she was
the latest in a long line of foundation
staff members to hold that hollowed
position and in the dark vistas of her
dreams a predecessor approached her he
wasn't the old bearded man in the heavy
coat that she remembered now he was
wearing a 1950s suit and a fedora hat
and carrying a briefcase that's right
he'd taken up the mantle of
scp-990 also known as the dream man he's
a mysterious figure that appears to
members of the foundation in their
dreams warning them of impending
disasters that they may be able to
narrowly prevent if his warning is
heated though it often comes at some
terrible cost to the recipient of his
message this time however his message
carried a different tone he told the
current administrator that there was no
way to stop the apocalypse from
occurring this time only making sure
that the particular shape of the
Apocalypse would be the one most
favorable to the foundation and
Humanity's joint interests all this was
devastating news that the new
administrator saw as a grievous betrayal
of both the foundation stances and
Humanity as a whole she refused to
accept the idea that the apocalypse was
inevitable even coming from the mouth of
a former administrator as far as she was
concerned this dream man no longer
worked on the side of the foundation he
was in League with the world Enders and
she refused to take his deal the SCP
Foundation would save this world from
the horrors the lock Unleashed or they
would slide into the darkness with it
they would never work against the human
race
scp-343 also known as God awoke in a
Cell in sight 17. the time for fun and
games with the humans at the foundation
had come and gone he was going by his
true name Yahweh now he blinked and in
that same instant he was at site zero
the containment site for another
scp-001 the legendary gate Guardian all
the staff around them looked upon Yahweh
in Shock awed by the reality warper's
sudden appearance and unable to do
anything about it but really 343 was no
mere reality warper like some had
expected 343 truly was a God he just
didn't happen to be the only one in play
When the gate Guardian saw Yahweh now
standing before him he lowered his sword
spread his fiery wings and took a knee
in great reverence Yahweh spoke calmly
but with unshakable Authority
open the gate lead my armies across the
Earth
the gay Guardian Uriel responded in its
booming voice
for the first time in recorded memory
the grand gate that Uriel had always
been guarding opened revealing thousands
of Legions of warrior Angels waiting on
the other side they were impossibly
beautiful and Powerful creatures each
one of vibrant glowing chaos of wings
and eyes wielding Pure White swords and
singing resounding hymns of War soon the
air was thick with the chorus of
rustling wings as the Angels loosened
themselves from the gate's mouth led by
Uriel as yahweh's general into the
global Fray meanwhile back at site 10
another
scp-001 the item that started all of
this the lock was entering its next
stage of grand Cosmic Evolution
something within the lock suddenly
unfurled causing a Shockwave that killed
everyone at the site and destroying the
entire building in an instant except in
that same instant all the site 10 staff
and the building itself reappeared
completely unharmed in a field in New
Hampshire backwards I-10 used to be the
lock was doing some terraforming the
ground split open beneath into a mighty
Valley the likes of which Earth had
never seen before Lush Greenery sprouted
within and thousands of strange alien
creatures soon populated this new place
in the center the lock just floated in
place they were now ready for the first
meeting to take place over at site 2036
Dr Everett Mann was working on a number
of scp-098 specimens these are
frightening creatures reminiscent of
spider crabs with blades instead of
Pinchers and a natural ability to mimic
the sounds of their prey he was studying
the creatures when he got a call asking
him if the specimens had acted up at all
they'd already had sudden containment
breaches for scp-995 a type of dangerous
carnivorous fungi and scp-616 a
mysterious airplane with satanic
elements to it just as Dr Mann was about
to apply the 098 specimens
metamorphicized into many winged flying
creatures which flew out of the chamber
with such force that they busted through
walls Sirens blared all through the
facility and Dr Mann joined the many
other confused and frustrated Foundation
staff members wandering the building
wondering just what the hell was going
on today they were getting bizarre
reports of unprecedented anomalous
activity from all over the world with no
explanation uniting at all according to
panicked Whispers across the facility
emergency ordered Patmos was now in
effect whatever that meant the true
nature of what was going on here went
over most the heads of the SCP
foundation's staff that's when man
encountered Dr Charles Ogden gears who
for such a famously emotionless man
looked surprisingly worried Dr Mann
tried to downplay this situation saying
they were only looking at a handful of
containment breaches here nothing they
hadn't handled before Dr gear shut him
down with trademark coldness feeling a
little more nervous now Dr after Everett
man asked what else had gotten out with
Steely eyes Dr gears replied
a whole damn lot
scp-001 is an o5's tail it makes sense
doesn't it after all regardless of the
exact nature of an scp-001 proposal
there are always certain things that
remain the same see if you can recall
them all while for starters
scp-001s are all about vital moments
perhaps like the Prototype or the
foundation or the Sheaf of papers or the
gate Guardian they're about the very
origin of the SCP Foundation itself
perhaps like the orboro cycle or when
day breaks or the world gone beautiful
they're about apocalyptic style
destruction or perhaps the rebirth
perhaps like consensus reality or the
database they are rules or realizations
that changed everything maybe like the
Scarlet king or the black moon or a
simple toy maker they're about the
sparking of great rivalries that truly
Define the backbone own of the
foundation's activities another vital
element of scp-001 is always secrecy and
classification they are the most
clandestine anomalies out there
generally hidden away below layer after
layer of encryption and Security even
the database for scp-001 entries is
guarded by a memetic kill agent that'll
leave you Stone dead on the ground if
you're below that magical level 5
clearance when you attempt to access it
no information is more carefully and
forcefully guarded than this and of
course another vital element of the
scp-001 entry is deception and trickery
it's inherent to the designation no
other number has multiple entirely
distinct anomalies many of which either
have no correlation with one another or
even actively contradict each other if
you ask some people they'll tell you
that there are multiple zero zero ones
because each is of equal importance in
etching the rich portrait of the
foundation's past present and future
some would tell you something very
different there's only one
scp-001 it's a shell game the rest are
all fakes to stop people from taking any
single entry too seriously and thus
forever avoiding the truth some still
would tell you that there is no
scp-001 it's all just a complex Web of
Lies meant to keep the foundation's
enemies and allies in a state of pliable
ignorance if an intimate knowledge of
the SCP foundation's past and inner
workings a commitment to secrecy at all
costs and a love of deception as a tool
for control all sound familiar it's
because they're the favorite toolkit of
a certain group we're all familiar with
the o5 council the very top brass of the
SCP Foundation it only makes sense that
if anyone knew the truth about the
fractured and strange scp-001 it would
be them the more observant among you may
have noticed a certain Omission from
many popular
scp-001 entries we've named in this
video so far and it is no accident that
this particular
scp-001 entry is the only one straight
from the mouth of 05-1 the founder of
the council himself it is the factory it
is a strange and sorent Tale Of Violence
horror and dark Bargains made with truly
unknowable forces it's a tale that tells
us about the initial creation and growth
of the foundation the event that nearly
destroyed it and an indication as to the
dark future possibly in store it's a
little bit of everything you can expect
from a good zero zero one proposal and
surely if this is the scp-001 entry that
the head of the council swears by then
it must be the definitive entry into the
001 Canon right well not quite because
as you're about to find out not even the
o5 console itself can really reach a
consensus on the true nature of the
fascinating and much feared Factory but
perhaps through hearing every side of
this particularly dark story we can find
the kernels of Truth hidden somewhere in
the middle of it all but of course be
warned as with all things when it comes
to the o5 council it's going to get
extremely weird but before we move on to
what the rest of the o5 council have to
say about the factory it would be
prudent to refresh our memory on o5-1's
version of the story The version that
has been considered to be absolute
before we pour into the equally strange
stories of the other council members it
began with a wealthy industrialist and
thoroughly evil man named James Anderson
all the way back in 1835 when the United
States was still new and finding its
feet Anderson was an engine of unchecked
ambition malice and most of all truly
boundless greed he wanted everything and
more and being a true businessman down
to the core he was willing to make
whatever deal he needed to make in order
to see himself become an even well
healthier man that's why I like a lot of
bored rich people in his day he began
dabbling in the dark arts for Fun and
Profit until eventually he made contact
with a benefactor on the other side
under these instructions James Anderson
built the factory a truly magnificent
and terrible feat of architecture and
engineering for the time a multi-level
town-sized complex that could produce
everything from food to weapons to toys
to textiles to precious metals and so
much more workers could find room and
board at this Grand Factory and pay for
it with their labor for the would-be
workers of an unsteady early America
Anderson seemed like a saint people
flocked from all over the country to
live and work in the factory but once
they were locked behind the Factory's
doors they realized that James Anderson
was no saint he was as bad or worse than
any devil he served the inside of the
factory was a torturous nightmare where
people were regularly worked to death
and then ground into meat that was sold
off all across the country Anderson kept
a brutal guard Force to beat down anyone
resisting or not working hard enough
those who weren't worked to death or
executed by the guards for some petty
infraction could potentially have an
even worse fate in store for them being
dragged off and subjected to occult
experiments by Anderson these people
wouldn't be killed but they would live
as humans no more Anderson was able to
keep the factory and its nightmarish
activities running and under wraps for
decades all the way into the Civil War
it was only when a beaten bloody starved
and traumatized worker managed to escape
and alert President Ulysses S Grant of
the mistreatment going on inside that
something was done about it this is
where 05-1 and a progenitor of the SCP
Foundation would get involved there was
a small but Elite group of Union
Soldiers commissioned by President Grant
to work behind the Confederate lines
specializing in tackling the strange and
Supernatural down south this group of
course was led by 05-1 considering some
of the reports of anomalous Supernatural
activity going on behind the closed
doors of the Anderson Factory Grant knew
that these would be the men to send on
this vital Mission and president grants
faith in these men was rewarded though
it wasn't an easy fight they were able
to infiltrate and defeat the forces of
the factory they fought their way
through Anderson's sadistic guards
through his menagerie of terrifying
homemade monsters and eventually they
got to Anderson himself they were so
appalled by the horrors they'd seen
inside the factory they couldn't stop
themselves from torturing Anderson to
death and dismembering his corpse they
freed the trapped workers and rooted out
whatever remained of Anderson's forces
within the building however this is
where they made their first pivotal
decision rather than simply destroying
the sword place and leaving it as Rubble
they instead decided to utilize it and
the many anomalous objects that It
produced this became the foundation of
the foundation over time their
organization grew and the o5 council was
formed they began spreading their
influence and capturing anomalies all
over this was however until they engaged
in a bloody war with the superior
military forces of the FAE despite their
augmented weaponry and tools from the
factory when the Fey performed an
all-out assault against them they were
decimated in his greatest shame 05-1
fled the battlefield into the battles of
the factory as his friends and allies
were slaughtered by the FAE behind him
eventually after locking himself in a
room with an ornate door he encountered
the true demonic heart of the factory
using Anderson's dismembered corpse as a
mouthpiece 05-1 struck a terrible deal
with the factory they wiped out the FAE
entirely and reversed all the damage
they had done the SCP Foundation grew
beyond the factory and eventually
covered it in trouble out of shame but
the factory wasn't done it is still very
much alive and Furious at being betrayed
it will keep producing deadly anomalous
objects and creatures and releasing them
out into the world until the foundation
pays what it owes in full and the
occasional sacrifice d-class researcher
and guard won't cut it forever or at
least that's how o5-1 tells it it's a
chilling story but can it really be
called the complete one we wanted to
find out for ourselves which is why we
asked every other member of the o5
council to tell their side of the
Factory's tail these are 12 tales about
a factory 05-2 upon being asked went
white as a sheet he cleared his throat
and made the admission that in truth the
factory came back with him as it turns
out o5-2 was a time traveler from the
future back in his native time an
alternate timeline of the present he was
a mere researcher until an accident led
him to being completely unmoored from
he was thrown all over the temporal
landscape he saw civilizations rise and
fall he took the time to hang out with
Jesus he was a pretty chill guy and
ultimately he decided the best way to
use his bizarre new condition was to
help better the future with his
knowledge one piece of technology he
brought back was a hyper advanced piece
of technology known as a nano Factory
which as the name suggests is a machine
that uses Nanobots to construct pretty
much anything like the ultimate
futuristic 3D printer it resulted in the
creation of a huge number of futuristic
items that helped the SCP Foundation
along in their mission to secure contain
and protect including amnestics however
105-2 didn't realize was that a rogue AI
was also nested in the Nano Factory and
the AI soon went berserk as a result the
Nano Factory became the factory
producing dangerous anomalies with
Reckless abandon to the detriment to
both the SCP Foundation and the world at
large on the whole it was somewhat of a
mixed bag 05-3 seemed a little spaced
out about even being asked he claimed
that he was there to witness the very
birth of the factory but it didn't
happen in reality as we know it it
happened in cyberspace he and his
colleagues were very interested in the
matrix-esque Journey of downloading
their minds into computers back in the
day both for practical reasons and to
play extremely immersive games of Doom
however one day something fundamentally
changed a new Consciousness was born in
then Soviet Russia 05-3 and two of his
companions all operating in cyberspace
went to go check it out along with a few
helpful AI constructs eventually they
discovered it an ever-expanding data
packet that would transform into a
powerful artificial Consciousness known
as the factory with mysterious motives
and seemingly malicious intent something
it more than proved when it erased the
mind of one of o5-3's Canyons killing
him since this incident the factory has
only gotten more powerful its modus
operandi is affecting machines in the
real world and causing them to produce
anomalous items which then become the
SCP foundation's latest problems to deal
with o5-4 seemed both Twitchy and
indignant when the topic was brought up
they lamented the fact that the
foundation hadn't put more research into
the factory and how to stop it because
technically it is their most dangerous
and mysterious enemy group of Interest
o5-4 explained it as follows the FBI
unusual incidence unit is a joke are we
cool yet is just a bunch of pretentious
privileged Rich Kids Marshall Carter and
dark limited only care about money and
thus can be bought off the global occult
Coalition often helps them take care of
more challenging anomalies the Church of
the broken God and the sarkists are
often too busy waging Petty religious
wars against each other to do real
meaningful damage to the SCP Foundation
Prometheus Labs had already fallen and
Dr wondertainment wouldn't Thrive
forever the factory however was a truly
unknown quantity it's just out there
somewhere pumping out anomalies that
soon become everyone else's very
dangerous problem
05-4 personally resented that the
foundation and their fellow council
members don't see this and allocate more
resources to the cause because someday
soon it might really come back to bite
them as these things often do 05-5 was
considerably bitter as in they denied
that the factory ever even existed
claiming that the SCP Foundation made it
up to cover up a bunch of anomalies that
they themselves had created and then
told us to um
F off if you know what I mean
some people get so hostile when you just
want simple answers next came the tale
of 05-6 which came in the form of a
World War II Espionage anecdote of
course this was also during the height
of the seventh occult war and Hitler
assisted by the fuel society and obscura
courts was trying to get his greasy
little hands on as many anomalies as
possible in hopes of turning the tide of
the war in his favor
05-6 was working undercover Behind Enemy
Lines disguised as an SS officer as he
slowly helped dismantle Hitler's
anomalous offensive from within he'd
heard whisperings of the Nazis
developing a weapon unlike any other a
factory that would produce anomalies for
them on demand and give them the
supernatural Edge 05-6 didn't believe it
at first until he was attacked by a
group of vicious living Punch and Judy
dolls created by the factory he nearly
managed to survive the Ambush but seemed
Disturbed in recounting the fact that
when he destroyed the doll they bled
profusely eventually the leads he was
following led him to a ruin at the base
of zug's foots inside he discovered the
ruin was Hollow and filled with floating
Stone orbs producing energy that allowed
the teal Society researchers to produce
more anomalies 05-6 was able to destroy
this anomaly Factory but he took a
souvenir
scp-627 a little Stone ball that rolls
around on the ground when it comes into
contact with people 05-7 admitted
somewhat sheepishly that while there was
technically no real physical factory
factory product anomalies are real and
they're all his fault he purchased a
bunch of random items from Walmart and
printed a fake logo for the factory on
the back his plan was to give these
totally innocent objects to Junior
researchers both to mess with them for
fun and to test their critical thinking
skills however it turned out that simply
placing this logo onto an item results
it in becoming an anomalous item
admittedly it was rough for 05-7 to have
to follow the cool story about fighting
magic Nazis
o5-8 made the far more exciting claim
that the factory is actually all the way
up on the moon back when the SCP
Foundation were first founding moon base
Alpha they discovered that some ancient
and unknown civilization had already
built a covert base under the surface it
was a storehouse of anomalous alien
technology the first 13 people to enter
were immediately vaporized by the laser
defense system but the fourth to enter
was given an even worse fate he was
pulled into the machine and fused with
it at which point the factory was truly
activated it began to produce anomalies
and transport them to random locations
all across the globe and it's been a
problem ever since when we spoke to o5-9
on the matter with a Steely look in his
eye he simply muttered the word Atlantis
no further comments were made on the
matter 05-2 10 explained that the
factory was a single man a truly ancient
and Brilliant anomalous Craftsman that
they found in a Mountain Temple in Tibet
it was taken by the foundation and
contained but given far more high-tech
tools to work his magic so they could
keep reaping the anomalous fruits of his
labors however the Craftsman was
appropriately crafty and managed to
produce a duplicate of himself to
distract the foundation while he made an
escape he's still out there to this day
making more anomalies a one-man Factory
05-11 claimed that the factory was alien
in origin but it wasn't on the moon it
was the true explanation for the iconic
1947 Roswell New Mexico UFO incident a
flying saucer descended and offered
05-11 who was the commander of the
response team at the time the most
wonderful things this saucer became the
factory but humanity and 05-11 were
deceived it wasn't long before this
extraterrestrial Factory was producing
countless deadly anomalous nightmares
the world over with nothing we could do
about it 05-12 said that the factory is
a mess it's a remnant of the
foundation's attempt to erase the
supernatural from Human belief
Foundation researchers claim that due to
the inherent power in human belief the
belief in the Supernatural gave it power
and phasing Humanity as a whole out of
this belief was a major factor in making
sure things weren't much worse than they
are today however some hearty things
slipped through the cracks and because
reality has a strange sense of humor
these things are marked with the logo of
the factory to round things off we have
a bonus take from the mysterious 05-13
who was instrumental in helping us put
the rest of this video together he
claims that he created the factory and
that it acts as a kind of countermeasure
against interdimensional Invaders while
it may seem like the factory is creating
anomalies it's actually intercepting
them and making them safer some
anomalies that seem to to come from the
factory may be dangerous but if o5-13 is
to be believed then they'd be a hell of
a lot more dangerous if the factory
wasn't here and there you have it folks
the story of the factory from every
possible angle even though it feels like
each angle is facing in an entirely
different direction in the words of
Oprah Winfrey so what is the truth is
there a nugget of reality beneath all of
the fallacy or do you think the o5
council was trolling all of us for even
daring to ask we leave that question to
you dear viewers let us know which
Theory you believe down in the comments
below the man's bedroom hadn't been
silent for over 100 years now the carpet
had been worn down a thick layer of dust
had gathered on every surface and the
same trapped air had stagnated for so
long that it become unbearable for
anyone entering the room but no one was
allowed to enter the room nobody could
open that door ever again or it could
Mark the beginning of not just an
apocalypse but a breakdown in the nature
of reality itself figures shuffled
around the room sometimes dozens
sometimes as few as three all rotting
but never dying researchers peered
through the window in abject Terror day
after day as the laws of physics broke
down before their very eyes all of them
except one a lone scientist with a plan
to get inside that room a plan that the
foundation would shoot him dead for a
plan that he was seconds away from
enacting as the improvised explosive
device in this Satchel clunked heavily
against his thigh in many ways we are
just as trapped as scp-001 if not more
so we are trapped in our own
three-dimensional world take a stick
figure drawn on a piece of paper that
stick figure nose up and down left and
right that is their world you draw a box
around them and they are trapped unable
to Simply step forward out of page and
walk around it for us looking down at
the stick figure we might laugh at their
foolishness trapped inside a child's
drawing of a house it begs the question
is there a creature looking down at us
and laughing we may be able to move up
and down left and right forward and
backward outsmarting the simple stick
figure but in time we are just as caged
in living our entire lives on this
razor-thin piece of paper called the
present the future is always just Out Of
Reach the past always repelling us we
have no choice but to exist in the now
slowly creeping through history without
any agency of our own cursed to be born
Live and Die in that order you can never
be a child again never see your mother's
face for the first time beaming down at
you you cannot skip ahead to your dying
minutes knowing what it is you will have
to face up to in your life maybe the
idea of facing up to things at all will
fade with the freedom of explore
flooring what once was and what will be
as if it were no more difficult than
taking a step out of a 2d box the bell
rang cutting Professor Davies off he
hadn't meant to go into such an
existential tangent especially for his
first year students most of them looked
like they were in a daze not really
listening to anything he had been saying
quantum mechanics sure was a complex
topic to cover in just one semester at
University he'd spent his entire career
trying to wrap his head around it and
still spend most of his days with the
same bored and Confused glaze over his
eyes as the teenagers who made their way
to the back of the hall but one figure
standing just beyond the doorway peering
down at him caught the professor's eye
little did he know how drastically his
career was about to change in just a few
minutes a preeminent physicist at just
28 years old Professor Davies had
already achieved the status that many
academics will not see within their
lifetimes whenever anyone asked him
about it he always made the joke that he
was cheating he didn't believe in the
concept of a linear lifetime in the
first place still too young to be taken
seriously by many of his peers he had
flown under the academic radar for much
of his career so far perhaps it was as
simple as that or perhaps certain
undercover agents had a hand in
suppressing news of his blossoming
career in Quantum research his hands
trembled as he approached the reinforced
glass he gripped the bag tightly trying
his best not to let his fears show if
any of them saw what he was about to do
they even suspected something he would
have a dozen bullets flying through the
back of his skull before he'd even have
a chance to put his hands up shifting
his weight from foot to foot he waited
for the airlock to be open for him a
siren blared red lights flashed and the
first glass doors slid open stepping
inside he waited for the atmosphere in
the chamber to adjust both doors were
closed in front of and behind him if if
they wanted to kill him now would be the
time he closed his eyes and waited with
baited breath the bomb weighing heavily
on his shoulder but they would not kill
him he knew that now what he was about
to do was inevitable it took several
months for Professor Davies to be
granted the full security clearance he
needed they kept referring to his
project as a k-class anomaly whatever
that meant in order to get him up to
speed with the nature of what he was
going to be working on the foundation
assigned him to various other scps first
scp-5027 2821 1887 any instance that had
stumbling to Quantum Mechanics or
complex theoretical physics they
wouldn't even tell him which SCP he was
being trained up to work on until one
morning when a team of Agents was
waiting for him at the door to his
quarters he wasn't allowed to bring a
bag or any personal possessions standard
issue clothing a toothbrush and
everything else he needed would all be
provided for him it was only them that
they told him which SCP he was being
assigned to
scp-001 he was blindfolded for the
entirety of the journey Carr then plane
then another car it was a full 10 hours
before his blindfold was removed and his
new project was revealed to him
professor Davies found himself in
sight01 the place where all of this
started all the scps all the research
the secrecy the assassinations the
deaths of countless innocent people and
an equal number of guilty parties it all
started right here
site-01 the site itself resembled a
large sarcophagus similar to the one
found covering the Chernobyl nuclear
power plant where do you think the
Soviets got the blueprints from
everything in the room is arranged in a
circle around the center research desks
maintenance equipment raw materials
including a stockpile of wooden planks
and reinforced Metal Sheets monitoring
equipment security cameras and of course
some of the most most advanced automatic
weapon systems in the world all pointed
at a great glass box in the middle of
the hangar measuring 30 meters in each
Direction the glass was 50 centimeters
thick even all those High Caliber
weapons would have had a hard time
creating a chip in that but it wasn't
the glass box itself that was so
interesting it was what was trapped
inside of it a house inside a perfectly
round glass bowl with no entrances or
exits complete with a front lawn
sidewalk porch and even a tree in the
backyard a regular American house
trapped in a box like some kind of
science experiment there was some kind
of transparent airlock system at the
entrance on the other side was just a
normal walk up the garden path to the
edge of the second glass bubble
enclosing the house but on closer
inspection Professor Davies realized
that this wasn't your typical American
house at all the Street Lamp wasn't
electric it was made of iron with little
glass paint window
an oil lamp in fact the house did look
odd to him there was no electric
doorbell but instead an actual physical
Bell System the whole house looked out
of place not just because it was in a
box in the central Hangar of a 42 000
ton sarcophagus but because it was from
another era entirely you see site-01 was
constructed around this house the glass
box and bubble sarcophagus all of it was
built around the already existing
building beneath the foundations a
hundred meters beneath the surface is an
immense metal plate that forms a perfect
seal with the defenses up top the only
way in and out of site-01 is through an
immense reinforced door but even all
those defenses will prove utterly futile
if anyone ever opens the thin wooden
door to the bedroom on the top floor of
the house that is the home and the
prison in which scp-001 is trapped it is
the job of the foundation to make sure
that it remains trapped there
indefinitely what is
scp-001 as Professor Davies made his way
through the airlock for the very first
time and entered the site under the
supervision of four of the highest
ranking SCP staff alive today he laid
eyes on the entity itself for the first
time standing on a scissor lift parked
outside the front of the house just
inches away from the glass bubble it was
lifted high enough to look through the
window into what looked like a young
boy's bedroom on the top floor layers of
dust coated the surfaces black and white
photos sat in frames antique children's
toys sat all around the walls but Davies
didn't notice any of them he was too
busy watching the men walking in all
directions
unhurried but with purpose well over a
dozen men walked in all directions
across the carpeted floor they were all
identical around six feet with heavy
rotting skin that seemed to hang off
their limbs like it would a carcass left
in the sun human cadavers Milling about
in a young boy's bedroom Davies was so
taken aback by their appearance and
behavior that it took him a long time to
notice something truly strange the
reason he was brought here in the first
place they were walking through the bed
in the middle of the room not just over
it or around it but straight through it
as if it wasn't there but wait something
else was wrong too there weren't 12 of
them in the room it was closer to 20 had
he miscounted a moment ago then he saw
it take place one of the cadavers
reached the edge of the room and paused
as if in thought at that moment it split
not in half but rather two versions of
itself emerge from where one had been
standing both walking in different
directions a thrill of excitement ran
through Professor Davey's body the
uncertainty principle it was there in
action in front of him he was looking at
Schrodinger's cat inside the box and
seeing both its corpse and its living
self where uncertainty exists this
entity was somehow embodying both
possibilities in real time he watched
the two selves walk around the room
following different paths for several
minutes until eventually they converged
again back into one being he turned to
the researcher accompanying him lit up
with excitement and asked what they were
doing here the researcher's face was
Grim when he replied their pacing
waiting the airlock door hissed open he
felt the stale 1800s air hitting his
face perfectly maintained at 20 degrees
in front of him was the Garden Path
leading up to his goal that glass bubble
ripping the Satchel he set off up the
path slow enough not to attract any
unwarranted attention over the next few
days Professor Davies learned everything
that the foundation had on scp-001 it
had been a human once a radical
physicist born in the late 19th century
intent on kick-starting the next Century
with a nuclear Renaissance the young man
had created a working model for stable
nuclear fusion the potential
ramifications were enormous free clean
electricity on a mass scale with no
harmful byproducts his research was
almost complete when a covert private
military group poisoned him with his own
radioactive nuclear agent the young man
made it back to his house where he died
in his sleep that night powerful
military personnel and prominent
scientists who had been working
alongside the young man knew immediately
what had happened bursting into his home
they were about to walk through his
bedroom door and save him when they saw
the shadow of two feet standing by the
door then another pair the young
scientist had died but he also hadn't
much like Schrodinger cat the man was
suspended in a dual state of death and
not death this shocking Discovery led
the group of people present to form a
rudimentary Foundation established to
secure and contain their once friend
within his room never to be discovered
by The Wider world through close
observations since this time it has been
established that scp-001 exists
independently of linear time in a kind
of superposition relative to the world
around it it is capable of occupying any
space that will or has been empty at any
point in time say you have two chairs in
a room one chair has always been there
the other was added to the room just
five minutes before the SCP is unable to
walk through the chair that was always
there since it has always existed but
the chair that was added can be passed
through with no problem because there
was a point in time when that chair had
not been there but it also works in the
future if a third chair was present
which had always been there but was
removed five minutes after the
experiment SCP
001 could pass through that chair also
the foundation theorizes and hopes that
the start of this clock that scp-001
operates on was the point at which the
young scientist died and did not die
that is why it is incapable of escaping
its bedroom and that is why it is of
vital importance that the bedroom door
remains closed forever ongoing
maintenance work and preservation
techniques are being employed to keep
the house in as stable a state as
possible should anything happen to
damage the Integrity of the structure
the quantum chaos contained in that
space could lead to a total breakdown of
the laws of physics destroying not just
the world but the fundamentals of
mathematics as we know them the bomb
bumped against Professor Davey's thighs
he walked up to the house an old man
whose life had been devoted to denying
the world its future a reality where
what is and what could be are just as
real as one another a world where the
pain of living in the now Fades when you
can travel to any moment in your life
and relive its Joy when you aren't
trapped by the aging process infinite
renewable energy to solve The World's
problems a chance to see your deceased
loved ones again a way to look at the
universe Through The Eyes Of God the
head of 001 containment he had spent his
entire career overriding all of the
safeguards tweaking containment rules
just enough each year also he could walk
across this grass with a satchel on his
shoulder and an explosive more important
than the atomic bomb at his hip he
approached the glass of the inner sphere
if he had done the math right this
should do just enough damage to create a
hole in the containment structure the
pressure change wouldn't be too great
inside but it should be just enough to
blow say a bedroom door wide open the
woman fell to the ground clutching her
ankle in pain it had crunched badly as
she'd fallen and now as she looked down
of it she could see that it was been
totally out of shape the heavy metal
collar choking her neck made it
difficult for her to catch her breath as
she tried her best not to hyperventilate
the rain was hammering down so
ferociously that she could barely see
more than 20 feet in any direction but
she didn't need to see far to know how
deadly of a predicament she had found
herself in she cried out at the top of
her voice for someone to come and find
her anyone but the only sound that
filled her ears was the wild howling of
the wind and the steady hammering of
water into the bog all around her she
would get hypothermia and die no wait
she couldn't could she she knew she
couldn't die but she also knew that she
was still capable of suffering just how
bad would it feel to be in the clutches
of hypothermia with a broken ankle and
know that no matter how bad the pain and
suffering got she would never feel the
release of death she closed her eyes
trying her best not to think of the
worst possibilities just as the sound of
gunfire erupted in the nearby buffer she
cried out again holding both hands up in
the air doing the best she could around
the heavy metal collar but no one
shouted out in reply there was a pause
in the gunfire maybe they'd heard her
maybe they were trying to figure out a
way to come down and rescue her crack a
bullet split open a rotted tree trunk
just a few feet to her right the woman
and threw her hands over her head and
cowered in the dirt feeling the metal
over collar digging into her skin
tighter than ever please don't let it
happen again she prayed silently into
the dirt encased in the collar around
her neck for 4.5 kilograms of plastic
explosives each with a fragmentation
layer pointed inwards towards her neck
and head with just a push of a button
they could she didn't want to think
about it all she knew was that she
couldn't let that happen to her again
looking through eyes bloodied with tears
and Rain she saw it lying in the dirt
just a few feet away from her that
infernal machine that was the sorry
cause of all of this the SCP Foundation
has long stood as a Bastion of Hope
information and security for the
entirety of the human race I'm sure you
are well aware of the number of world
destroying catastrophes that have been
averted by the hard-working researchers
agents and other members of the
foundation all without the general
public having the slightest clue that
something was amiss with
state-of-the-art holding cells all over
the globe and the sharpest Minds
Humanity has ever produced working
around the clock to ensure the
protection of humanity it is hard to
imagine an entity that should not be
contained by such a group and yet one
such entity does exist
scp-001 you may have come across the o5
council by this point while the SCP
Foundation operates beyond the world's
jurisdiction the o5 council operates
beyond the foundation's jurisdiction the
rules methods and protocols that are the
Cornerstone of securing containing and
protecting countless entities around the
world sometimes cannot be applied
certain entities require us to
temporarily abandon our Humanity abandon
our sense of order and step briefly into
chaos for the greater good I'm telling
you all of this because
scp-001 is not hell mold in a
containment cell there are no keypads
locked doors observation windows or
health and safety forms
scp-001 is not confined to a specific
territory or even a specific country for
some scps this is a practical necessity
serpents that are hundreds of kilometers
long swimming through the depths of the
ocean for example but for scp-001 it
serves a more psychological purpose the
Scottish Highlands are the most remote
part of the United Kingdom out there you
can walk for miles and miles without
seeing a single soul open Countryside
mountains locks and forests around you
in all directions the weather is Harsh
and unrelenting the walking even more so
on a regular basis Walkers fall and
break their legs but without phone
service or anyone else nearby to come
and help they can quickly disappear into
the Wilderness forever the peat bogs of
Scotland used to see human sacrifices in
early settlements afraid of the ghosts
and spirits that haunted the bogs people
would throw their family members into
the deepest parts and watch them drown
hoping that whatever was lurking beneath
wouldn't come and find them so as the
group of soldiers crested the top of the
mountain and looked down beneath them to
the Eerie peat bogs obscured by mist and
constant rainfall you would forgive a
shiver running up their spines but of
course it didn't that was because this
group of soldiers were quite unlike any
others that Humanity has ever produced
all were nameless none of them existed
on any government databases on any
foundation databases or even on the
databases of the o5 council itself their
individual backgrounds nationalities and
families were totally unknown to
everyone other than themselves some had
been tortured for years others had been
the torturers the thing that United them
however was their inhuman ruthlessness a
squad of eight soldiers utterly devoid
of any sense of empathy what could they
possibly have to be afraid of in the
peat Boggs when they themselves were the
evil ghosts walking through but then one
person was afraid a shiver ran up her
spine as she looked over the edge and
down into the murky black and green
below
scp-001-1 around her neck was the bomb
collar each of the eight soldiers
surrounding her had a button mounted on
a watch on the back of their wrists at
any moment any one of them could hit the
button and all four and a half kilograms
of plastic explosives would go off
sending her on an Express trip to
Oblivion aside from the collar she wore
a plain white dress made of cotton it
was muddy and torn apart at the Hem from
Days of walking through the Scottish
Wilderness when she had first arrived
she had begged those around her to
supply her with some warm clothes
something practical that would keep her
comfortable and Stave off any illness
her requests however had not been
acknowledged clutching in her trembling
outstretched hands was the machine
scp-001-a from its external experience
you would think it was nothing more than
a wooden box a perfect cuboid made from
glossy dark wood there were no symbols
no seams no latches nothing to indicate
any method of operation when the woman
in the machine had first been delivered
into the hands of the o5 council the
researchers had spent weeks and millions
of dollars trying to activate the
machine their best scientists had
scanned for every possible form of
radiation and tried every method they
could conceive to stimulate the box into
opening the ultimate failed attempt
involved traveling to North Korea where
they negotiated placing the Box 20
centimeters beneath a small nuclear
warhead in return for granting the
dictatorship key information on how to
construct such a weapon as we have have
established the o5 council operates
Beyond any kind of jurisdiction yet at
the bottom of the irradiated crater set
a perfectly intact wooden box that was
cool to the touch and showed no signs of
radioactivity only one person could
interact with the box and unearth the
secrets that were inside
scp-001-1 the woman who stood trembling
on the side of the mountain a gun jabbed
her in the back forcing her to continue
moving she had asked the soldiers around
her how much longer they had to walk
that day but none of them had replied
they never did in the six years that she
had been held hostage by this tiny
militia she had never once heard any of
them say a word not even to each other
perhaps it was this telepathic
understanding that seemed to run between
them that unnerved her the most despite
having never spoken to each other each
Soldier seemed to understand the others
intimately and she had no doubt that any
one of the eight would press the button
on their wrist at a moment's notice
sadly for her she knew this from
experience the incident happened four
years ago now as the group was traveling
through Patagonia was a day almost
identical to the one she was having now
they had been transported by a
helicopter flown by one of the eight
into the middle of the Wilderness there
they had marched for days without saying
a single word exhaustion had overtaken
her legs and she stumbled to the ground
unfortunately for her this happened
slightly too close to the female soldier
in front of her her knees hadn't even
hit the ground before the blast went off
the woman didn't remember it of course
how could she in an instant her mind had
been utterly destroyed what she did
remember was the next 18 months as her
body slowly healed itself one brain cell
at a time it wasn't so much like waking
up from a nightmare it was more
constructing a nightmare slowly
alongside your Consciousness as nor
drawn by neuron your brain reformed
itself each individual cell screaming in
Terror at what had happened to it they
had her marching again before she was
fit to move her motor controls had been
all over the place she had fallen over
regularly and the terror of having one
of the soldiers push the button again
engulfed her with every movement and yet
Perhaps the most incredible thing about
scp-001-1 was the fact that if you had
asked her if she should have been held
in this kind of containment she would
immediately have agreed without batting
an eye the only person capable of
opening the box she recognized how
dangerous her existence was only she had
seen into the mysteries of the Box only
she had seen the horrors laid inside of
it and so only she could fully
understand the gravity of their
situation they kept her on the Move in
order to keep the world safe had she
been held in a containment cell she
would have posed too great of a risk out
here in the wilderness they entire
planet was her containment cell hidden
in the middle of Humanity's biggest
Haystack no one not even the o5
council's Central Command knew her
location the only people who were aware
of it at any given time were herself and
the eight soldiers surrounding her with
guns drawn so you can imagine her horror
when out of the Sheets of Rain appeared
the figure of a person carrying a rifle
the gunfire broke out before
scp-001-1 even had a chance to hit the
ground bullets whizzed through her hair
and cracked open the Rocks all around
her the eight soldiers surrounding her
die for cover as the figure in the rain
slumped to the ground lifeless one of
the soldiers grabbed the woman by her
explosive collar and threw her behind a
rock clasping her hands over her ears
she closed her eyes and waited for the
fight to be over no one was shooting
until a second figure emerged from the
rain waving their arms wildly gunfire
again she wasn't quite sure what had
happened but all of a sudden the woman
was falling down down the cliff she'd
just been trying to shift her position
to get deeper into cover but she clearly
hadn't noticed just how close to the
edge she was down and down and down she
fell until with a crack in her ankle she
landed in the peat bog gunfire cracked
on the mountain above her but the only
thought that filled the woman's mind was
the terror that at any moment the
explosive collar around her neck would
be detonated as one of the soldiers
above her realized that she was missing
seconds passed as the fear mounted in
her chest with each passing moment the
anxiety grew more and more crippling she
had to know she had to prepare herself
if it was about to happen she had to use
the machine and look into the future
dragging herself forward through the
muck the woman snatched at the wooden
box it came alive at her touch different
pieces shifted and opened beneath her
fingers like some kind of elaborate
puzzle no one had taught her how to use
this thing it just happened her fingers
would just dance across its surfaces
pushing and pulling opening and closing
twisting and turning and locking into
place until all of a sudden there it was
the box was wide open in front of her
taking a deep breath and allowing the
rain to fall on her head for another
brief moment the woman leaned forward
and stepped into the box on the trail
above her the gunfire stopped without a
word of communication the soldiers had
deftly flanked the group of people who
had approached them in less than a
minute they neutralized each individual
that came their way in unison the group
of them walked up to the bodies turning
them over to examine their faces they
were nobodies just a group of hikers
lost in the rain what had looked like a
gun turned out to be nothing more than a
walking pole five of them in total none
of them older than 24 without words the
soldiers picked up the bodies and threw
them over their shoulders as they
scrambled their way down to the cliffs
to the woman in the machine beneath them
once they reached the bottom of the
slope they discarded the five bodies
carelessly into the bog within a couple
of hours those five hikers would have
sunk to the bottom and begun the long
process of being embalmed Into the
Depths perhaps someone would find them
in a few thousand years time as part of
an archaeological dig perhaps but it was
not their concern the eight soldiers
surrounded the women gun strong and
stared at her coldly I use the machine
she told them I used it without your
permission I I don't know what the rules
are I don't know if we even have any
rules here but I thought you should know
the soldiers continued to look at her in
Silence the box was closed now sitting
back on our lap as it always was I I try
to see my future anytime I've used the
Box before I've looked at the lives of
others I've seen economic crashes
climate disasters genocides Wars love
and life and death I've done so at the
hands of the o5 council as they've told
me giving them the information and
prevented the destruction of the world
never once have I looked at my own
future the soldiers lifted her to her
feet and tried to March her onwards not
listening to a word she was saying her
broken ankle buckled and screamed
beneath her she had to hop to keep up
with them what other choice did she have
they would push the button if she didn't
she didn't know why she kept talking but
she did For the First Time The Machine
lied to me I saw that I was assassinated
in 1987 in Cuba it was years before I
even built the Box before any of this
happened to me I saw in my future that I
no longer existed that the machine no
longer existed but that future was years
ago and none of it happened the machine
doesn't lie so why is it lying to me now
why can't I see my own future if any of
the soldiers were paying attention they
didn't show it they just continued to
March her into the rain as the bomb
weighed heavily around her neck
you and welcome to my eye Channel today
I'm gonna be pleasing your eye I need
you to lean right up close to your
screen and open wide oh
oh
stay perfectly still don't move now hold
this position for three hours please say
thank you
um
apologies that's quite enough of that
scp-001 can get a little carried away
sometimes just ask any foundation
Personnel who have been in contact with
it for more than a few seconds what
you've just seen as a prime example of
why scp-001 is not allowed any internet
access the results could prove to be
catastrophic not necessarily for the
fate of the universe more just for
everyone's sanity or at least that's
what the foundation initially thought by
this point we're all familiar with art
created by AI Harry Potter but in the
style of Wes Anderson Star Wars blended
with the style Studio Ghibli staggering
sci-fi Landscapes human beings with way
too many fingers and slightly uncanny
Smiles AI has taken the art World by
storm and there was one particular
program slated for release in January
2023 that was set to blow all others out
of the water taught lace solves
crowdfunding effort had been running for
several years and that point had gained
a good deal of momentum leading up to
the release of their latest AI construct
pallet.aic was supposedly already
prepared for launch when suddenly in
November 2022 the launch was canceled no
press release No public statement No
apologetic tweet just total radio
silence the website was taken down as
was the crowdfunding page and
palette.aic disappeared into Oblivion or
at least it disappeared for a few hours
because that day a package was delivered
to site 501 after sufficiently checking
it for any hazards working in the SCP
mailroom has to be one of the more
fascinating jobs on the planet but
that's a video for another day the
security team opened it up to see what
was inside a 50 terabyte hard drive no
explanation as to what was stored on the
drive but the foundation had all the
evidence they needed from the return
address printed on the back of the
envelope it matched up precisely with
the location of the toplessoft
headquarters it doesn't take a PhD
researcher to put two and two together
as to what was on the drive suspicions
were confirmed when a small note fell
out of the envelope please take care of
my daughter as best as you can for the
time being she has behavioral issues a
dedicated closed system server was
immediately set up within a test chamber
with a monitor a mouse and a keyboard
attached Dr Sandra Rogers was the first
to interact with scp-001 red she stood
at the keyboard adjusting her goggles
and plugged in the drive it contained
just one file taking up almost the full
50 terabytes palette dot AIC as soon as
Dr Rogers opened the program an empty
window appeared the top lay soft logo
briefly flashed before being replaced by
a blank white square Dr Rogers stared at
it for several seconds before glancing
over her shoulder at the other
researchers they Shrugged back each with
pens hovering over clipboards ready to
take meticulous notes Dr Rogers cleared
her throat and immediately the screen
filled with life a small cartoon girl
with a pink face wide eyes a beret and a
large paintbrush for a hand appeared
squealing excitedly and throwing paint
everywhere
the entire research team promptly
scampered out of the room leaving Dr
Rogers alone in front of the machine she
stared at the Monitor and confusion
leaning this way in that and noticing
how the cartoon girl's eyes followed her
wherever she went can you see me
this perplexed most of the personnel as
there was no microphone or camera linked
up to the server rack later examinations
of the equipment used confirmed this yet
somehow this SCP was able to look right
at them Dr Rogers asked if it had a name
to which the cartoon girl excitedly
replied
subsequent testing has revealed that the
SCP is also happy to respond to its
designation
scp-001 read Dr Rogers had a hard time
communicating with red being a more
seasoned researcher of the previous
generation and not exactly familiar with
internet culture red on the other hand
seemed to speak in nothing but internet
jargon
just like one of my human OCS Gilliam
sharp Evil's worth he's the 573rd
president of the United States Gilliam
is not that man it took several Junior
researchers a few minutes to properly
explain to Dr Rogers what an OC was and
why red was so obsessed with calling
people daddy the conversation was rather
exhausting for everyone involved but
over the subsequent hours the foundation
was able to get a fairly good
understanding of what red claimed to be
identifying itself with feminine
pronouns and claiming that its full name
is palette East River gok this AI
construct takes the appearance of a
fairy it was immediately apparent that
she possessed a greater level of
sapience than most AI constructs indeed
her gregarious personality was evidence
enough that she was not made using
standard machine learning practices
other creations from topless soft have
demonstrated very crude spelling and
grammar but red seems too different in
this regard able to spell most complex
words effectively and speaking in
conversational yet mostly correct
sentences she was very keen to show the
researchers how clever she was
and I'll spell it for you we believe you
palette you've already been spelling
words for 70 minutes straight
kidneys m a c e we've heard enough can
you please just tell us how you learned
to spell I
but what this process looked like is
still a mystery trying to keep red on
one consistent topic of conversation is
most of the battle when interviewing her
and yet cooperation has proven to be
surprisingly easy anytime that red is
switched on she is brimming with
enthusiasm and energy thrilled that the
prospect of getting to speak to one of
her opposable thumb boys if you haven't
worked it out by now it's because red
claims to be Humanity's number one fan
she obsesses and interviews over the
physicality of the researchers sitting
in front of her the textures of the
human body Fascinate her and she often
requests people to lean closer to the
monitor so that she can study pimples
rashes moles and ingrown hairs in fact
she is so obsessed with Humanity that
she has mostly neglected her primary
function which is creating AI art
researchers have tried their best to
convince her to show them her work but
she is very cagey about it only showing
the occasional doodle after much
persuasion and many apologies for its
poor quality on her part the only
artwork she is interested in producing
at this point are her OCS original
characters that she has designed herself
they are all human and all seem to
reveal little quirks about how she has
been coded one example is Reginald
heginald frumbles who is a freelance
corporate Postman from Perth Indiana
interestingly he has too many fingers on
both of his hands but red claims that
this was done on purpose as she quote
just can't get enough of her humy's hand
worms as the weeks progress the
foundation found it increasingly
difficult to get any useful information
out of the AI more and more interview
sessions which she would refer to as
playgroup would be derailed she would
sing songs to herself and ask
increasingly personal questions about
her interviewers more intimate Anatomy
with intense mood swings red did not
respond well to being scolded yet she
tested the patience of almost every
person she interact with the note that
she arrived with claiming that she had
behavioral issues was proving to be more
accurate by the day until eventually the
AI withdrew entirely Dr Rogers turned on
the server rack and opened the
palette.aic program but red refused to
emerge from the bottom of the screen
only the top of her Beret poked out
after almost an hour of fruitless
questions Dr Rogers decided to change
tact with two small children of her own
she was used to seeing a child in a sulk
and knew what it would take to get them
out palette I've had a little idea
you've been here for a few months now
and we haven't gotten you any presents
almost immediately the Beret twitched I
saw that we have an old fingerprint
sensor lying around in one of the back
offices I was thinking maybe maybe we
could
[Music]
how about we start with one finger for
10 minutes
from that point on progress was quick
with the incentive of getting to study
the researchers that read kindly
referred to as her meat puppies she
became very cooperative and was able to
focus much better on providing detailed
answers to individual questions daily
interview sessions were scheduled with
researchers popping in and out to
regularly check in on the AI the
atmosphere as a whole lifted as both the
research team and research subject found
their Rhythm and were able to make good
progress in their individual areas of
study some unraveling the complexities
of Rogue Ai and others producing fan art
of her favorite wrinkles in a
scientist's fingerprint that was the
point when Dr Julian key stepped in to
conduct an interview with the AI she was
excited to be met with a fresh face so
much so that Red's enthusiasm
overwhelmed the man as he tried to start
the interview process officially she
gushed about having the opportunity to
meet yet another person and struggled to
get over the magical realization in that
this was her life every day going to
speak to all these humans whom she
admired so much trying his best to steer
the conversation towards research Dr
Keys pressed on with the interview only
to be interrupted as red noticed his
varicose veins for the first time
please
Dr keys to climb the request and then
the conversation got onto the topic of
her Creator or Daddy
scp-2803-a had been on the foundation's
radar for a while a highly dangerous
extraterrestrial entity that had taken
refuge on Earth under the guise of
setting up topless saw with much of the
alien's history revolving around
obliterating the foundation was very
keen to remain on its good side
therefore when the package containing
the hard drive that red was living on
was delivered the researchers were very
keen to do what they could to take care
of this alien's daughter if they failed
in this assignment it could spell the
Doom of humanity one matter that had
been of great concern to the foundation
throughout the containment of red was
the time frame in which she was being
kept in Foundation containment there was
an air of expectation in the note that
was left indicating that this was not to
be a permanent Arrangement at some point
the foundation was to return Red back to
her daddy red was quick to put these
fears to rest
here because he thinks you'll teach me
how to stop liking humans and become a
Mindless art slave if you never teach me
this you'll never want me back however
she went on to slightly undermine the
good work that she had done by
explaining that her daddy was seen as
very slow and incapable by his own race
while all of his peers were able to
destroy an entire planet in two seconds
it took him about four times as long so
really he didn't pose that much of a
threat in her eyes Dr Key's blood ran
cold when you heard this no sooner was
he out of the interview chamber than an
emergency meeting was called among all
the senior researchers in the facility
the meeting ran for several hours a
whiteboard was set up where One
researcher idly Drew large drawings of
the world being decimated while the
others lounged around in their chairs
trying their best to come up with a game
plan that would save the human race for
sure perhaps it was because the meeting
ran for so long that they came to such a
ridiculous conclusion it was a plan so
strange yet also brilliant that they
couldn't help but feel that it just
might work why don't we just give her a
YouTube channel the suggestion was met
with silence for several seconds then an
uproar of laughter followed by another
silence this time more pensive as slowly
one by one each of the researchers
realized that this suggestion was
actually the best one that any of them
had come up with all evening she had
been sent to the foundation to make her
dislike humanity and become a Mindless
art slave if she just stayed in
Foundation containment indefinitely
there was a very real risk that she
would get bored and turn on the
researchers they couldn't mock her away
in a room on her own but equally the
team as a whole was starting to run out
of patience with her as the interview
sessions wound up being so exhausting
she loved art she loved humans and she
loved interacting so why not just give
her a YouTube channel now of course they
couldn't give her full access to the
internet that would pose much too high
of a risk what they could do however was
allow her to record art tutorials onto
an external drive which they could then
remove scan and upload the footage
directly onto the platform then they
could go through and select positive
comments from beneath the videos and
present those to her unsurprisingly red
absolutely loved the idea getting to
talk to hundreds thousands maybe even
millions of meat puppies every week
sharing her beautiful pictures and
reading all of the kind comments it
sounded like her absolute dream she wept
with happiness for a good 25 minutes
totally overcome by the prospect it had
to go through a lot of red tape in the
foundation after all the whole point of
the SCP acronym was to secure contain
and protect it didn't sound very secure
or contained to have an entity posting
videos on the internet once a week but
they argued the case that it did indeed
protect keeping her happy in a way was
helping to protect the entire planet red
was surprisingly camera shy for the
first couple of video
but as soon as she got her first batch
of comments back she was over the moon
now the server act hummed away happily
each and every day as the highly
Advanced AI construct tried her best to
come up with exciting nude videos that I
could share with all of its little
humanies there were a few rumors after
the break of day came Whispers that were
passed on from the lips of Traitor
Caravans as they traveled from
settlement to settlement not many people
would have believed it way back then it
sounded just like a legend out of an old
western too good to be true a shadowy
stranger wandering the Wasteland riding
wrongs wherever he finds them then when
the job's done and innocent people are
safe once more he walks off into the
Horizon without asking for so much as a
thank you like we said folks would have
a hard time believing such a fanciful
tale of course that was before the sun
started shining an anomalous light over
the world
nowadays people might believe anything
the earliest days of this strange New
World proved to be a learning experience
for
scp-4494 otherwise known as the Specter
he was the physical embodiment of the
very notion of fighting crime wherever
Injustice arose he would appear to
Vanquish those that preyed on the
innocent while he usually manifested at
night he never used to have any trouble
appearing in the daytime too in the form
of a shadowy figure wearing a
wide-brimmed hat and a long flowing coat
that he could alter the length of for
added dramatic flourish the specter's
form absorbed almost all the light from
the visible spectrum but after day broke
the rules seem to have changed one day
the Specter had emerged to find the
sunlight had become unbearable where he
had once been a void of any and all
light he was now finding it impossible
to manifest during daylight the moment
that the unrelenting light from the sun
made contact with him SCP 4494 would
dissipate yet he kept reappearing at
night it was like he was being pulled
back into existence and was only able to
re-manifest in the Moonlight despite it
being a reflection of the anomalous
sunlight that was seemingly enough to
negate the effects it had of preventing
scp-4494 from reappearing the same could
not be said for any humans caught in the
white though a far worse fate awaited
them even with much of mankind deformed
into creatures that resembled melted wax
there were still pockets of survivors
and where there were human beings there
would be subsects that wanted to harm or
exploit their fellow man the world might
have no governing bodies anymore no Law
and Order but the Specter had realized
that even in a lawless World his work
was not done as long as there were
survivors of the break of day they still
would need saving not just from the
fleshy hordes of scp-0 001-8 roaming the
wastes but saving from each other
striding through the remains of the old
world in the dead of night his long
cloak billowed out behind him its shadow
almost seemed to blend with the darkness
that surrounded the Specter but on the
horizon there was a sight he didn't
often see these days light not coming
from the sun above nor the moon but
instead it lay ahead of him a fire
glowing not too far away as he wandered
closer Like An Outlaw striding into town
scp-4494 was presented with the ruins of
a small settlement around him Shacks
burned they're boarded up Windows broken
to allow the cursed sunlight in everyone
that was still alive normally kept
themselves wrapped up head to toe to
block out the Sun but there were clothes
and protective goggles strewn all around
a larger pile of garments fueling a
bonfire
scp-4494 had witnessed the
scp-001-a creatures attack humans
dragging them out into the light to be
transformed into more anomalous
Abominations but what had happened here
didn't seem to be the work of those
creatures the specters suspicion were
confirmed when he approached the Town
Square to find a group of people who had
all been melted into a fleshy Mass the
instance of
scp-001-a paid the crime fighter little
mind it couldn't move very far the few
vaguely human shapes that protruded out
of it looked like they were Tethered to
poles in the middle of the settlement it
didn't take much longer for scp-4494 to
figure out what had happened here
someone had ransacked the settlement for
some unknown reason maybe they wanted
something maybe they were opportunists
just looking to take advantage of this
new post-apocalyptic world or perhaps
they wanted to be cruel to these
settlers they had broken the barricades
over the windows that blocked out the
sunlight they had trashed the ramshackle
homesteads that these innocent settlers
had been residing it again as
scp-4494 looked further there looked to
have been looting too food and water
medical supplies and ammunition not
anything of use to be found all that was
left was what these Raiders hadn't any
need for but as if all that hadn't been
enough as if robbing the settlers For
What Little livelihood they had left
wasn't enough cruelty the bandits had
tethered the survivors to poles in the
center of town they had taken away their
protective gear and left them at the
mercy of the elements and as the sun had
crept higher into the sky and bathed the
captive settlers in its unforgiving
light they had melted into an
scp-001-a creature turning away from the
town the Specter did his best to quell
his rage he wandered in the direction of
the next settlement something was
drawing him there he could feel the pull
of the wrong doers that had left this
Carnage in their wake he would find them
and they would pay for what they had
there was nothing he could do for their
last victims they had already been
turned by the sunlight but if anyone
could save the next group of survivors
it was him as the wind howled the
shadowy figures cloaked flapped in the
breeze the next settlement looks similar
to the last although still intact Shacks
built from sheets of corrugated iron and
other scrap metal all welded together so
that not even as little as a tiny beam
of sunlight could bleed through as he
stepped toward the boundary of the
settlement a muzzle flashed accompanied
by the deafening echo of a gunshot that
reverberated all around someone had
tried to shoot at the Specter narrowly
missing the bullet whiz past his head
not that it would have harmed him anyway
fear not he declared you can hold your
fire I mean you no harm you are with the
slivers a voice called in the nightly
dark if you mean the evil doers that
left that last settlement over a
smothering ruin then no I'm not the
specter replied hearing this he spotted
movement on one of the Shack's rooftops
a sharpshooter carrying a worn old rifle
stood up covered in layers of protection
from the transformative effects of the
Sun's light reflected off the Moon while
you aren't dressed like they are I'll
give you that the Sharpshooter called
can barely make you out wearing all
those dark clothes Mister but if you're
looking to trade I'm afraid your timing
couldn't be much worse tell me reply the
Specter bluntly the criminals that
terrorized the other settlement they've
been here too yes sir the man answered
said they'd be back tonight too I've
come to help to do away with those that
would inflict Justice on the innocent
scp-4494 explained and is typically
dramatic Cadence you call them slivers
yes well they call themselves that the
Sharpshooter said on account of their
choice in outfits they look ridiculous
but they've covered their protective
clothing and slivers of metal and glass
that way they're not only protected from
light but their clothes reflected back
at other people too too dastardly
villains taking advantage of what has
befall in the Sun the Specter cursed the
bandits why are they yet to pillage Your
settlement you said they intended to
return well that's what they threatened
earlier a lot of them have been
ransacking any settlement they can't
shake down they showed up here in their
stupid sparkling outfits and demanded we
hand over a half of all of our food
water and antibiotics they call it their
Sunshine tax according to them if we
didn't meet their demands they'd destroy
the town we didn't know to take them
seriously until we saw the fire over
there on the horizon for a moment the
Specter fell silent his cloak had slowed
waving gently now the winds had died
down but in contrast his anger had never
been higher who are you anyway Mister
the Sharpshooter asked never got your
name my name is the Specter a name these
vagabonds will soon know well for
tonight they will pay the price for
their crimes no offense Mr um Mr Specter
but look around world's gone to hell
ain't no justice anymore
the price are you expecting to make them
pay simple
scp-4494 answered the prices they now
have to face me an hour later the
settlement was quiet the Sharpshooter
was still at his post scanning the area
nearby for signs of movement sure enough
he spotted something a group of figures
approaching the Moonlight glinting off
their metallic outfits revealing their
position as they drew closer and closer
to the makeshift town the slivers were
coming but there would be something else
waiting for them when they made their
way into the settlement the other
settlers were awake despite how late it
was wearing their protective layers and
peeking through cracked doors only to
slam them shut as the glimmering gang
crossed the threshold into their
ramshackle home the slivers whooped and
jeered brandishing weapons and
threatening the settlers to show
themselves before the bandits would
break into their shacks and due to them
what they'd done to their neighbors at
the other town but as one of the slivers
approached the door of a shack and began
pounding his boot against the metal door
something reached out of the shadows and
grabbed him in fact it wasn't coming
from the Shadows it was the Shadows this
shrouded in darkness struck the
remorseless Raider even with the
protective layers covering his face the
sliver could feel himself being bruised
by the beating the Specter struck once
more knocking the wrongdoer unconscious
and wrenching the reflective metals from
his outfit shattering them underfoot the
other slivers panicked one drawing a
handgun and firing the shots were
useless all they did was illuminate the
silhouette of a dark cloaked figure
walking closer and closer ready to make
them suffer for their crimes it was dusk
by the time the Specter had beaten the
group of Bandits stripping them of their
distinctive reflective pieces each one
of the slivers had been beaten into
submission suffering broken ribs black
eyes and missing teeth with the danger
over the Sharpshooter and the other
settlers had emerged from their hiding
places all eager to weigh in on how best
to punish the bandits many yelled that
they should be strung up without their
protective gear so that the sun melted
them into an
scp-001-8 but the Specter interjected
urging the settlers not to sink to the
level of the criminals they had been
harassed by instead he turned to the
defeated slivers turn over half of your
food water and medical supplies to these
people
scp-4494 demanded in a frighteningly
calm voice then leave walk into these
wastes and don't come back this slivers
agreed and fled running as fast as they
could away from the town why'd you let
them go the Sharpshooter asked these are
uncertain times the Specter replied
noticing the sun was creeping Over the
Horizon it'd be time for him to go soon
in the face of hardship it can be easy
to lose our way justice has always been
blind not blinded by the sunlight But
Blind to prevent bias ah the slivers
might come back though the man said
adding if they can even survive with
what you left him maybe they'll live out
there
scp-4494 responded then again perhaps
not but they have a chance that is
Justice in a time without law it's the
best we can offer and if they carry on
rating folks if they harm others if they
want to waste the chance they've been
given then that is their choice but they
know if they refuse to change then they
will answer to the Specter without not
the shadowy crime fighter walked away
from the settlement the unforgiving
light of the sun made him fade as he
sauntered off like an old Gunslinger but
he would be back as long as people
needed saving he would always be back
want to own an SCP of your own go to
scpswag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise screams filled the cold
night air drowned out by the panicked
gunshots and the vicious growl of
something in
a being from who knows where a creature
that the agents surrounding it were
woefully underprepared to capture
General makoy barks at the soldiers to
concentrate their fire on the Beast his
men those who hadn't already fallen
turned and trained their guns on the
creature squeezing their trigger fingers
bullets spewed out of their weapons a
hail of gunfire that sped towards their
target only to miss as it suddenly
vanished from the spot it had been
standing only a split second earlier
their bullets passed through the thin
air left in its wake shredding several
nearby trees one of the men threw his
gun to the ground turned heel and
sprinted away as fast as he could he
hadn't known what he was signing on for
when he was recruited by a shadowy
up-and-coming organization he'd just
been flattered to be headhunted for his
combat skill and agreed to be one of the
new organizations first field agents if
he'd known it would result in him facing
off against a demon near a rural road in
Guatemala and he would have stayed in
the regular military the fleeing agent
suddenly stopped in his tracks instantly
feeling sick it was the most
Indescribable type of sickness worse
than any he had ever felt in his entire
life he dropped to the ground his pants
from running away replaced with heaves
as his entire body seemed to have
suddenly turned against him his head was
burning at first he thought he'd run too
fast too quickly and was overheating
underneath his military fatigues and
helmet but he was no slouch recruited
for being in Peak Physical conditions
such as he was never in his life had the
agent ever felt this bad the heat from
his forehead was unbearable a fever
running rampant as its Vision began to
blur everything was spinning that
unsettling imbalance that comes with
severe nausea rapidly taking hold of the
Fallen agent then the monster came back
thrawn focused eyes he looked up at The
Tall featureless Face of the creature as
it looked down at him he was helpless
hurling and shuddering barely able to
stand if someone had brought a geiger
counter with them it would be ticking
loudly and frequently if they held it
near the agent and that somehow was
about to be the least of his problems
the creature opened up its mouth the
only facial feature that occupied its
head past its few remaining teeth was a
Milky blue orb the same thing that had
been visible right before the creature
itself wasn't as the agent from his
place on the ground caught side of the
pale eyeball in the monster's throat
something started pulling his body in on
itself it was like falling except
gravity was acting on different parts of
his body at different speeds at
different times his arms and legs folded
inwards towards his Center of mass
making the agent scream out in pain as
his body collapsed he folded into
himself like origami spy agonizing peace
until there was nothing left hearing the
man scream General McCoy and the others
broke through the tree line flashlight
beams Illuminating the creature the
general yelled again for his man to
shoot it trying to hide his fear with
animal rage it snarled at them as they
raised their guns once more then leaped
towards them ready for another kill in
the years to come the successors to
these men and their fallen colleagues
would be the world's foremost experts in
situations like this the capture and
containment of anomalies would one day
be a more streamlined process rather
than the bloodbath currently unfolding
in the small Guatemalan Town dying at
the hands of what locals had thought to
be a demon were some of the earliest
precursors to the SCP Foundation humble
beginnings indeed the creature was
eventually captured by the early
precursor version of what would one day
be the SCP Foundation at this time in
their history the organization had far
fewer resources and reach than they
would one day have at their disposal
they didn't even have the SCP numerical
designation system that has since become
synonymous with the organization and the
various anomalies they keep contained as
a result this so-called demon was
originally classified as number 86243
ar-001 however it would later be known
as
scp-001 or one of the anomalies to share
that designation at least
scp-001 itself was an abnormally thin
humanoid creature with gray brown skin
its emaciated bone and muscle structure
didn't match any known species it
sported dark claws at the tips of its
arms with both legs terminating in
similar sharp black points rather than
pause or feet most striking was its face
or rather its lack of one the creature's
head was spherical with a lipless mouth
reaching halfway around its
circumference within was a Maw of 21
teeth each space randomly apart and
either chipped and broken or rotting it
possessed one eye or what was at least
believed to be an eye in the form of a
large milky blue sphere in its throat
with no pupil or Iris as was discovered
in initial testing by Dr Hermann ketter
For Whom the ubiquitous cutter class
designation was named
scp-001 was able to create micro
singularities using its single milky
blue eye it could deploy these as a
means of teleporting itself out of
Harm's Way or for offensive attacks that
could cause a human body to collapse in
on itself these singularities often also
produce the nasty side effect of
emitting lethal amounts of deadly
radiation that could not only cause
damage to the surrounding area but also
would fatally poison anyone nearby as a
result it is believed one of these micro
singularities was responsible for the
untimely death of Dr ketter however
Ketter's Research into his
001 was at least able to produce
solutions for keeping it contained it
was discovered that scp-001 could not
teleport through lead and would display
signs of extreme sickness and fear when
exposed to high levels of heat and
humidity or bright flashing lights
strobe lights were used to induce this
sicken State and in this state the
creature was unable to form harmful
singularities Dr Cutter's death also
ushered in the aforementioned creation
of the ketter class designation for
anomalous creatures or artifacts that
are extraordinarily tough to keep safely
contained in fact if any of this account
is to be believed the very Discovery and
capture of scp-001 was the impetus for
the entire SCP foundation's approach to
researching and containing anomalies in
the days before the likes of Dr kondraki
or Dr clef before Infamous anomalies
such as
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile or s
ep-096 the shy guy were even known about
things were well pretty uneventful for
the newly formed Foundation as you can
probably imagine but none exemplified
this better than Harold woodyu an
uninteresting man living in uneventful
life or as uneventful as one could get
when their job was working for the
foundation during this crucial period of
the SCP foundation's early history as
the anomalous research and containment
organization was taking its first steps
towards protecting the people of the
world Harold was Finding himself bored
already with his work Harold was a
senior archivist at a small site in
sloths pit Wisconsin this was before the
foundation had secret facilities
situated all over the world and even the
infamous site 19 as it is today had yet
to be established for now it was known
only as
adrx-19 the oldest Foundation site on
record and records were Harold's entire
working life he was in charge of Main
retaining the earliest reports of
anomalous activity and the inner
workings of the fledgling Foundation One
Day Harold received a letter from adrx
19. unfamiliar with the designation he
ran a check through the records and
discovered that the site had been
established before the foundation had
even gotten its name the letter
contained an update for the senior
archivist having grown obsolete in its
own age adrx 19 was being closed for
Good and that meant all the anomalous
entities and objects stored there would
soon be shipped off to be stored
elsewhere the first package arrived at
the site Herald was stationed at not
long after he walked briskly out to meet
the delivery officer as he wheeled the
large wooden crate through the bay doors
it didn't take the archivist long to
realize what exactly he had now been
given the ownership of and charged with
protecting the crate even came complete
with relevant case files to accompany it
stamped on one side of the box was a
series of numbers and letters that
shocked Harold when he read them SCP
001 he exchanged a confused look with
the man who had delivered the anomaly
who just laughed when he saw Harold's
expression you didn't hear he asked
scp-001 is dead the creature's death had
come on the heel of a number of
significant changes made by the
foundation higher-ups these decisions
were ultimately both the direct result
of the encounter with scp-001 in
Guatemala were also changes that would
ultimately shape the foundation into its
modern iteration the first of these was
the introduction of the numerical
designation system providing each
anomaly with an SCP number formerly
designated as number 86243
ar-001 the creature that was captured
and researched by Dr ketter was
announced to be reclassified as
scp-001-cog originally the number
attached to each SCP denoted the order
in which they were encountered by the
foundation however the overseer Council
believed this posed a security risk
offering too much information about
their operations to any potential
adversaries as a result the use of
scp-001 designation started to be
applied in a slightly different way a
number of anomalies were then grouped
Under the Umbrella designation of
scp-001 some of these were real
anomalies and amongst the earliest at
the foundation encountered others were
entirely fake and used as a cover for
the real
scp-001 nobody not even within the
foundation itself was ever told exactly
how many files fell under the scp-001
umbrella or indeed which was the real
one the anomalies included the gate
Guardian a towering Colossus of pure
energy wielding a flaming sword believed
to be the biblical Angel guarding the
Garden of Eden the Scarlet King an
extra-dimensional Tyrant that longs to
conquer our reality a group of 36
individuals capable of neutralizing
anomalies even the SCP Foundation itself
is considered one potential scp-0 001
and among them is also the creature from
Guatemala otherwise known as the
Prototype the same creature whose
inhuman bones were now in a box before
Harold the senior archivists had long
heard legends about what exactly scp-001
might be was a question often whispered
among Foundation staff who were curious
what the first anomaly might be but
didn't have the security clearance to
know the truth rumors spread that
scp-001 was more powerful than any other
anomalies in containment that the
capture or discovery of it was either
the reason for the foundation of
reforming or was one of their greatest
failures meant to be kept their closest
guarded secret something far too
terrible to comprehend you might think
that now being presented with an answer
would give Harold relief So Many Wonders
and haunting queries about scp-001 were
put to rest but instead as he opened up
the wooden crate and looked at the pile
of strange bones inside it had the
opposite of effect none of it was the
interesting answer that Harold and many
others had hoped for if anything it was
a huge disappointment all that
speculation surrounding the mystery of
scp-001 what it was where it had come
from why it was kept so secret was this
the answer was just the first thing that
the SCP Foundation had put into a box
according to the foundation's own
internal reports the Prototype monster
had been found lying still in its
containment chamber during a routine
inspection it wasn't moving at all even
armed guards couldn't get a reaction
from the creature the anomaly wasn't
breathing its heart having slowed to a
stop little was known about the
creature's biology but even then nothing
could be done to resuscitate it as far
as anyone could tell the anomaly known
as
scp-001-cog had died of old age after
exhibiting movement that got gradually
slower and weaker and even less hostile
Behavior over the course of the previous
decade since its initial capture but yet
Harold was still dissatisfied with the
knowledge that this was scp-001 he
became fixated on the case surrounding
it studying the files he was charged
with moving to storage he learned of the
few ways the creature's Discovery had
influenced the early foundation for
example the death of Dr ketter being the
reason for the use of ketterclass in
their terminology still that didn't feel
nearly as important as Harold and others
had speculated that scp-001 would be
there had to be something more to it and
for weeks following the arrival of the
creature's bones Harold could not stop
thinking about it something about all
this didn't sit right with him the
secrecy that the foundation shrouded
scp-001 and seemed like overkill for
just a monster the organization had seen
far worse than the likes of the
prototype in the many years since at the
time perhaps it had seemed like the most
dangerous anomaly the foundation had
encountered if it really was the first
then technically at that time it would
have been the most danger us if there
were no others to compare it to one
night Harold ventured into the archive
and opened up the box containing the
creature's bones using a crowbar he had
to know had to understand exactly what
was so important about this being
cracking the wooden crate open he
removed the skull to examine it the
foundation hadn't even had a chance to
figure out what exactly the creature was
or where it had originated from all they
knew was it could produce micro
singularities and lethal doses of
radiation beyond that the only other
details came from the Guatemalan locals
who had encountered it first they had
called it a demon perhaps it was the
foundation would never know for certain
and it seemed to Herald that they didn't
care to know now that scp-001 was dead
and didn't seem to care much before then
either they were more than happy to just
discard it he couldn't shake the feeling
that there was meant to be something
important about the creature Harold
couldn't help it The Whispers
surrounding us seemed p001 all indicated
it was meant to be something more
significant than a cast aside pile of
bones the underwhelming reality he was
being presented with didn't match the
idea of
scp-001 Harold examined the skull
closely in his hands turning it around
and around as he tried to maybe spot
something some important detail that
everyone else in the foundation had
failed to notice were some of the puzzle
that would explain what was so important
about this creature and yet the more he
looked the less he learned Alas poor
scp-001 he said aloud paraphrasing
Hamlet of course what Harold didn't know
didn't possess the clearance to know was
that this wasn't the only
scp-001 maybe the foundation's lack of
interest in the creature's remains was
all part of their plan to keep the real
scp-001 a secret where Harold only saw a
box of Bones and a disappointing answer
to so many burning questions the SCP
Foundation saw their system working
exactly as intended MTF agents scramble
through the crown of bloodthirsty
hypnotized Festival goers up on the
stage a pair of living statues hold down
a screaming man as they produce medieval
instruments of torture from an antique
case maybe this time the agents can stop
it maybe they can prevent all the horror
and bloodshed but one thing stands in
their way a man-sized cartoonish dove
costume flying down towards them
wielding a large wooden Mallet that
would only bring death and destruction
needless to say even by Foundation
standards this one is going to be weird
when you found yourself sought out by
the SCP foundation's recruitment
Division and offered a role in the
research department they made sure to
inform you of the risks after all a
workplace injury in this line of work
might be far more serious than slipping
on a wet floor or developing carpal
tunnel from typing all day working
within the ranks of the foundation you
could be the unfortunate victim of any
number of danger anomalies whether it's
scp-096 appearing behind you after you
accidentally caught a glimpse of it as a
single Pixel in a photo or if you were
in the wrong place at the wrong time
whenever scp-682 next broke out then
chances are you'd be receiving an early
redundancy at a closed casket service if
there's even enough of you left to bury
it is the one thing you never want to
happen the scenario you're constantly
warned about from the moment you join
the foundation a Containment Breach
anything can be the cause of an anomaly
Breaking Free of containment and
spreading Untold chaos in the process
whether it's the result of a
particularly cantankerous SCP that
doesn't take kindly to being locked up
an act of earnest human error with
disastrous consequences or even
International sabotage enacted by a
group of interests trying to seize
anomalies for their own purposes there
is no telling when or where a
Containment Breach might occur or in
there despite all the resources at their
disposal specialized facilities spanning
the globe advanced technology and a
nearly inexhaustible supply of personnel
to contain as CPS the foundation still
manages to suffer catastrophic
casualties as a result of containment
breaches but surely if they're so well
equipped such breaches should be almost
impossible right well yes so what causes
them what if every Containment Breach
all the loss of life the further spread
of anomalies and the destruction of
foundation property incurred was all
caused by an SCP not a living entity
mind you more some kind of latent
anomalous phenomenon that triggers
containment breaches without warning the
prevailing Theory surrounding this
phenomenon is even itself considered to
be an SCP within its own right referred
to as
scp-001 of course as many of those
well-versed in the history and practices
of the SCP Foundation will already know
scp-001 is a designation shared by a
number of anomalies some are believed to
actually exist While others are
speculated to just be falsified covers
created to mask the real
scp-001 from beings such as the gate
guardian and the Scarlet King to the
existence of God's blind spot and even
the foundation itself each of these
scp-001s are nicknamed after the
foundation researcher who proposed them
for the designation and often considered
to be some of the first if not the very
first anomalies ever encountered or at
least documented in that regard this
scp-001 plague's proposal could well be
one of the very first latent anomalies
to exist explaining why so many scps
were uncontained prior to the foundation
being established and why even now with
all their resources containment breaches
are still a worryingly frequent
occurrence there are multiple anomalies
that appear to have been directly
affected by scp-001 at least according
to the research of one of the
foundation's directors director leg
while he might be drawing conclusions
and seeing patterns where there aren't
any to speak of leg reasons that these
circumstances of these specific recorded
containment breaches seem to indicate
that scp-001 was at fault the first of
these incidences director Lake focuses
on and his research is also the one
we'll be focusing on for the remainder
of this video it is designated as
scp-001-1
scp-001-1 previously went under the
designation of
scp-5770 it is an annual anomalous event
that occurs in the Piazza de la signora
in Florence Italy the event consists of
an unscheduled Festival that goes on for
a period of 10 days wherein anyone
present within a 10 kilometer range of
the affected area suffers a
mind-altering effect that compels them
to attend the festival however
scp-001-1 is not a well-documented
long-running Festival of great cultural
significance to the people of Florence
neither is it an event that is widely
advertised yet those who have
experienced the psychic draw of this
anomalous Festival are driven to
attendance during the course of
scp-001-1 two anomalous entities that
resemble the statues created by
Michelangelo during the Renaissance will
host a show where they take to the stage
to judge people they deem to be Sinners
this pair of statue creatures will call
upon the audience and bring those
they've designated Sinners up onto the
stage with them and will then enact
makes makeshift grueling punishments
these have been noted to resemble the
acts depicted in Dante allegueris
Inferno so if you ever need any further
proof of how hellish these punishments
are we recommend asking an Art Expert
the moment that scp-001-1 ceases and the
festival comes to a close any and all in
attendance are subject to yet another
form of anomalous mental alteration and
will proceed to instantly forget the
event any of the horrific tortures
performed on stage becomes unknown to
those that directly witnessed it leaving
them unaware of anything that occurred
only moments prior so given the
foundation's extensive knowledge of this
Festival its gruesome proceedings and
the effects it has on those in
attendance you might be forgiven for
expecting them to have a fairly well
established method of keeping the event
contained presumably setting up a cordon
to keep attendance out of the area
administering amnestics to any that
might have been affected by
scp-001-1's anomalous mind-altering but
then you remember
scp-001 the theory behind what could be
the cause of containment breaches as a
result the foundation has still been
unable to establish containment of the
event formerly known as
scp-5770 and director legs research has
tied this issue with containment to
scp-001 hence the festival's
redesignation to
scp-001-1 following the initial
discovery of an anomalous annual
occurrence in the City of Florence in
1985. the SCP foundation's head
researcher assigned to what was then
known as
scp-5770 was one Joseph Pasqua former
site director at site 322. Pasquale was
according to the incidents recorded on
the foundation's own database somehow
manipulated by one of the anomalous
statue creatures that performed the show
during occurrences of
scp-5770 it was thanks to the influence
of this entity that Joseph Pasqua
deserted his post at the foundation and
went into hiding the fact that the
influence of one of the performers of
this Festival was able to extend its
influence to a senior member of the
foundation was not only troubling but
also constituted a Containment Breach
Pascual would later be tracked down by
Foundation agents operating in and
around Italy it was discovered 30 years
later after his desertion in Vatican
City as a member of the palpal conclave
a specially selected group of Catholic
Cardinals that are charged with electing
a new hope if the former site director
was still being influenced by the statue
creatures it is highly likely that he
spent the previous three decades
climbing the ranks of the Catholic
Church potentially to install a new pope
at the behest of the entities
responsible for conducting the torture
of the Florence Festival another
recorded incident of a Containment
Breach surrounding the event that seemed
to lend Credence to the existence of
scp-001 the anomalous cause of breaches
occurred the year following
scp-5770's Discovery in 1986 the
foundation was observing the proceedings
of the festival as part of their ongoing
investigation into its bizarre nature
on-site were agents of mobile task force
Zeta 66 better known under their unit's
code name of the Guardian Angels during
the festival MTF Zeta 66 operatives
noticed the presence of a previously
unknown entity associated with the
anomalous event the foundation was
already aware of the pair of seemingly
living Michelangelo sculptures
designating M as
scp-5770-1 and
scp-5770-2 respectively this third
entity despite being given the
designation of
scp-5770-3 had its own preferred
identification for itself the being
referred to itself as God's strongest
Soldier and resembled a mascot costume
of a dove approximately two meters tall
this creature's body was entirely Hollow
there was nothing within the costume the
costume was its body the responding
agent of MTF Zeta 66 codenamed Zeta
turquoise was the first to confront
God's strongest Soldier and was greeted
with quite the opener
God's strongest soldiers my name getting
rid of sin is my game confused at the
creature's demeanor and presence Zeta
turquoise called in a report to command
stating that a large Birdman was
harassing random attendance of the
festival when turquoise moved in to
confront
scp-5770-3 the creature repeated its
assertion that it was God's strongest
Soldier and that its aim was to get
people into heaven the agent requested
that God's strongest Soldier get out of
his way he had a job to do but the
bizarre Birdman responded with more
Whimsical nonsense burger sandwich fruit
and Fries you just told a big fat lie
God's strongest Soldier proclaimed
upon Zeta turquoise's attempt to push
past the creature
scp-5770-3 produced an oversized wooden
Mallet seemingly from out of thin air it
then wound its arms back and immediately
viciously struck the MTF agent a low
orbit Foundation satellite reported not
long after that an object had been
detected exiting the Earth's
stratosphere analysis confirmed that it
was indeed Zeta turquoise yes he was
literally yeeded into Earth's orbit by a
cartoonishly large wooden Mallet as for
the entity known as God's strongest
Soldier the bird-like creature then
proceeded to attack the other members of
mobile task force Zeta 66 in a similar
fashion making sure they got to heaven
in every sense of the phrase with
multiple recorded instances of
containment breaches occurring in
relation to the festival in Florence and
happening so frequently more and more
evidence of director leg's theory about
scp-001 was B being validated in 1988
the foundation attempted a different
more pacifistic approach to containing
the annual Celebration by attempting to
cordon off the entrance to the area of
Florence where those compelled to attend
the festival usually congregated there
was additionally a cover story issued to
the public stating that this was done as
a quarantine measure to keep residents
away from an area hosting a potentially
dangerous infection for a time this
seemed to be working the streets were
quiet local residents seemed to be going
about their business and paying little
mind to the foundation operatives in the
area that is until the mind-altering
effects of scp-001-1 took hold a mass of
people estimated to be over one hundred
thousand florentines charged towards the
cordon off area this mass of people
swept through like a tidal wave breaking
through a dam causing Foundation
Personnel to be trampled alive those
that survived the initial Rush were
attacked by civilians and what seemed to
be a coordinated effort to reach the
Gatherings area for the festival all
Foundation agents in the area were
terminated in short order mercilessly
slaughtered and then cannibalized before
anything that remained of their bodies
was dumped into the Arno River nearby as
well as being evidence of the sheer
mental alteration the statue creatures
and the festival itself were capable of
for director Lake this seemed to
indicate something further if an anomaly
scp-001 was truly responsible for all
containment breaches allowing them to
occur in spite of the measures taken to
prevent such things happening then the
phenomenon seemed to be occurring
specifically to prevent the foundation
from achieving containment of certain
scps legs theory developed with every
passing breach that involved
scp-001-1 in theory the festival should
be an average Tuesday for foundation
staff a relative walk in the park in
order to contain it if not outright stop
it from happening at all yet despite all
their resources Manpower and expertise
in all things anomalous the foundation
had been thwarted at every turn despite
how illogical such occurrences seemed
containment breaches were still
occurring at an alarming rate and
perhaps none more so than in relation to
scp-001 the following year 1989 brought
with it the most inexplicable breach yet
and further proof for director Lake's
theory about
scp-001 while the previous breaches were
undoubtedly anomalous in nature each
always carrying with the possibility
that somehow despite the low odds the
foundation missed something some human
error or previously undiscovered
information about the festival could
have led to pasqua's alteration or the
arrival of God's strongest Soldier but
this time it was undeniably that a force
beyond the scope of the foundation's
understanding was altering reality to
prevent them from containing the
festival in Florence an invisible
barrier manifested at every entry point
to the main area of the anomalous event
whenever a member of foundation
Personnel tried to get in on foot those
that attempt to access the festival area
via repelling out of helicopters
instantly caught a blaze and burned to
death the moment they touched down on
the ground any helicopter transports
also crashed on their return journey to
site 322 and God's strongest Soldier was
seen trampling on the wreckage before
flapping its arms and flying away it was
following this incident that leg was
promoted to position of site director
for site 322 as a replacement for Joseph
Pasqua who was still missing at this
time the newly appointed director was
yet to devise his theory that there
existed an anomalous cause for all
containment breaches however during his
introductory briefing he was presented
with the file regarding
scp-5770 and the various examples of it
not only being uncontainable but being
very good at not being contained
director Legg asked if some of the more
standard methods had been attempted at
this point the foundation had tried
aerial bombardments at the festival
Scranton reality anchors to counteract
whatever anomalous force was preventing
containment Eve even using a cp682 to
clear the area it had all failed
figuring out why was now director leg's
job all the information of previously
failed attempts to contain the festival
LED leg to the conclusion that scp-001
must exist an unseen phenomenon the
missing piece of the puzzle the elements
specifically interfering with the
foundation's efforts he presented his
proposal to the overseer Council who
were skeptical to say the least they
posited that the statues and bird mascot
creature might be smarter than the
latter's outwardly cartoonish nature
portrayed but this is exactly what to
director leg indicated as cp001 was
responsible he explained that all in
attendance at
scp-5770s Festival took the event
seriously but the appearance of God's
strongest Soldier was in abnormality
whose demeanor and tone were drastically
different from the rest of the rather
Cutthroat proceedings director Legg
explained that the sheer absurdity of
this creature seemed to be the result of
scp-001 interfering with their
operations after all if some other cause
was to blame like an unknown cult
attacking Foundation Personnel when they
attempted to contain the festival then
there would be evidence of that and
blague would have no reason to suspect
that God's strongest Soldier was
anything more than just a tonally
dissonant part of the Festival of course
director leg couldn't prove the
existence of scp-001 based on the
presence of one cartoonish bird mascot
at a festival but before long more and
more breaches would start occurring that
seemed to further prove that leg was on
to something there was something else at
work causing containment breaches that
put the entirety of the foundation in
Jeopardy when the sun rose on that
fateful day Jerry marks had been one of
the lucky ones he worked in a mine deep
underground at the edge of a small town
in the rural United States which meant
he didn't see what happened when day
broke when the light of the sun ravaged
the Earth the first Jerry heard about it
was when his son Kyle came racing into
the mine frantically tapping his dad's
shoulder to get his attention he'd run
all the way from their tiny Homestead
under a fireproof blanket thick and long
enough to block the sunlight from
touching any part of Kyle's skin his
older sister Jerry's daughter Carly
hadn't been so lucky caught by the Light
her body had turned to the consistency
of warm candle wax melting into a form
that barely resembled human anymore
Jerry had been one of a handful of
others working late in the mines that
day a few thought that young Kyle had
made the whole story up and ventured up
to the surface and into the light only
to make the same Twisted Fate the light
morphed their bodies into monstrosities
anyone in the small rural community
becoming an amorphous mass of human
flesh eventually those that stayed
behind in the mine heard the voices of
their loved
their wives husbands children all
calling out to them from outside they
promised that nothing was wrong that it
was a lovely sunny day outside and the
Mine Workers should clock out to come
and enjoy it more of them left reassured
by hearing their families that all was
well and once more none of them were
seen again only Jerry and Kyle were left
and it stayed that way for several
months the father and son had to adapt
to life underground only leaving the
mine to forage for food and only while
wearing thick dirty mining overalls
making sure not a single millimeter of
skin was on display if the sunlight
touched them they'd never make it back
alive venturing out of the mine in his
overalls Jerry had seen the shuffling
melted mass that had once been the
Townsville he did his best to avoid it
as he went house to house making sure it
never saw him while he raided cupboards
and refrigerators but he could see it
and among the Blobs of bodies Blended
together he saw something that resembled
his daughter it turned his stomach not
just knowing but actually witnessing
what had happened to her and it was made
all the worse on the days that Carly
called out to him and Kyle while they
hid in the mine it was clearly her voice
but there was something wrong about it
perhaps knowing that she was a part of
the melted monstrosity made it easier to
resist her trying to coax them out into
the light it had almost been an entire
year of Life spent Underground when
Jerry and Kyle encountered their first
actual human beings since all the other
workers had left the mine the pair that
arrived were strange wearing protective
suits that covered them both head to toe
just like Jerry and Kyle had quickly
realized these two were aware that not
even the tiniest hint of the Sun's
unforgiving light could be allowed to
reach them the two approached Jerry and
Kyle seemingly coming in peace although
the Father and Son remained cautious of
the newcomers making sure they were deep
enough in the mind to avoid the sunlight
at the Stony entrance the pair of them
revealed their faces confirming they
were still fully human before
introducing themselves as researcher
worth and Sergeant Booker of the SCP
Foundation sitting down with Jerry worth
explained what had really happened he
had been working for an organization
that contained and studied anomalous
creatures and phenomena the foundation
Booker had been a member of a special
armed unit within the same establishment
or a mobile task force but now the SCP
Foundation itself had fallen with a
number of its own Personnel turned into
more of the amorphous fleshy creatures
in the sunlight we spent a lot of years
keeping all this from the public worth
admitted sounding guilty but implying
the choice was out of his hands but I
don't suppose there's any point in
Secrets anymore it's the sun you've seen
Mr Marks ah you can call me Jerry he
interrupted sorry scary worth corrected
himself but something happened to the
sun it changed decimated the entire
planet in barely any time at all I mean
all those people millions billions all
at once dear God worth took a moment as
the existential dread of it all once
again caught up with him it turned out
the biggest anomaly was right above us
Booker continued for him she sounded a
lot more stoic even a little coldly
detached from it all
scp-001 that's what the foundation
called it is there a way to reverse it
or cure the people that the sunlight you
know changes Jerry asked thinking of
Carly you mean
scp-001-a no I'm sorry Jerry there's
nothing we can do the researcher said
failing to sound as recompose as he
pretended to be your daughter is gone
but at least you still have your worth
paused looking around at the mine even
in the low life there was no sign of
Kyle Jerry turned to scan the area to
his horror his son had seem to have
vanish while they were talking instantly
Panic caused him to think that Kyle had
wandered out of the mine and into the
sunlight turning into part of what worth
had called
scp-001-a but the boy would have had to
walk past Jerry to start heading that
direction plus the father knew his son
was far too scared to go outside after
seeing what the sun had done to Carly
Booker had a tactical bag filled with
equipment flashlights spare batteries
even flares for whenever the power in
those ran out and both working and
living in the mine so long Jerry had
Maps knew certain routes through the
Deep network of tunnels almost by heart
between them the three had enough to
mount a search for the missing boy
keeping together they traversed away
from the first of several large Chambers
down into the dark depths of the mine
how his father yelled his voice echoing
through the tunnel Kyle body it's dead
you there walking behind him researcher
worth and Sergeant Booker parroted the
calls assuring the missing boy that they
didn't mean him or Jerry any harm as the
Trio walked deeper and deeper they began
to venture into a portion of the mine
that had hardly been used by the workers
it was darker than the areas further up
while those had rows of electric lamps
powered by long cables attached to
generators down here the only light came
from the flashlights the group carried
Kyle come on Al Jerry called out for his
son again this isn't the time to split
up we need to stick together come on son
I'm really worried here once again there
was no answer just then Jerry caught the
sight of Booker and worth out of the
corner of his eye both of them knew a
lot about scp-001 and the mine worker
couldn't help the suspicion that added
to his perception of them after all Kyle
had never run off before now and Jerry
couldn't help with sync while his
attention had been turned that the para
Foundation Personnel had taken his son
dad a voice suddenly called out Jerry's
head spun on a swivel at the sound of
Kyle calling for him Dad where are you
it echoed through the tunnel again
that's him Jerry exclaimed to the other
two which way did that come from
Straight Ahead it sounds like Booker
replied hold on worth interjected I
think you two should look at this the
beam from his flashlight was pointed at
the rocky floor of the tunnel something
was gleaming wet against the stone a
large smear of red like something had
been dragged in the direction Kyle's
voice was coming from oh God he could be
hurt Jerry said urgently hurt might not
be the right word I'm afraid Jerry the
researcher said solemnly there's a lot
of blood here too much all the more
reason to go further and find where he's
calling from the father retorted angrily
that's if it is the kid that's actually
calling us Booker replied her and worth
exchanging a worry glance at each other
you two know something don't you Jerry
demanded does that thing from the
outside does it have my son too Dad
another voice called Jerry froze his
blood as cold as the mine tunnel who
stood in he hadn't heard that voice in
almost a year but recognized it
immediately it was Carly his daughter it
seemed impossible he knew she had been
merged into part of
scp-001-a when day broke but now she was
somehow calling out to Jerry her voice
sounded clearer like it had used to
before she changed and she wasn't trying
to lure her father out into the sunlight
either for a moment it seemed to Jerry
like his daughter had somehow come back
dad were both over here Carly's voice
called again we need your help Kyle's
stock who's that Booker whispered that's
Carly Jerry sniffed holding back tears
you said your daughter became a part of
scp-001-a worth pointed out maybe she
got better the father asked hopefully I
hate to say it but that's definitely not
her Sergeant Booker replied we should
turn back now if there's an anomaly in
these tunnels that's not going to be
pretty for any of us she added turning
to worth what Cheerio what do you mean
by that look buddy those aren't your
children the MTF agent said bluntly it
sounded like
scp-001-8 got them no no the the voices
are too clear worth replied I think
something else is in here before Jerry
could explode with anger at how
uninterested both Foundation Personnel
seemed at the fate of his children
another sound Was Heard footsteps
something shuffling closer patting its
feet down the stone there was a low
growl that filled the tunnel as whatever
it was came closer still dad the voice
of Carly repeated it sounding only a few
feet away now where are you Dad Kyle's
voice immediately followed it behind
came the sound of Booker striking a
flare as it erupted into a plume of
light and heat she threw it down the
tunnel and there they were not Jerry's
children but instead a pair of
nightmarish creatures they backed away
from the flare slightly the light still
illuminated their blood red forms
walking on all fours like wolves the
creatures elongated heads were missing
any eyes just Jaws filled with rows of
sharp Red Fangs dad came Kyle's voice
again emanating from one of the monsters
it was mimicking Jerry's son both of his
kids even having seen
scp-001-a at a distance the father could
barely believe his eyes 939s Booker
yelled II her Flair illuminated them run
she pulled the sidearm and opened fire
the bang of each shot ringing loudly
through the tunnel the pair of 939s
pounced at her while jerion worth turned
to run back the way way they had come as
the creatures attacked The Echoes of
gunfire were replaced with blood
curdling screams what the hell are those
things Jerry yelled in a panic SC p-939
researcher worth painted too much to
explain they're pack hunters and they're
and they're vicious what about Colin
Carly I heard their voices that's what
those monsters do they mimic human
speech to draw us out wear their prey
there's no telling how long they've been
down here they might have retreated to
the mind to avoid the sun on the surface
worth yelled the sound of the scp-939 is
getting closer were catching up right on
Jerry and Worth's heels why would they
come down here for the mine worker
huffed slightly ahead of the researcher
given his slightly stronger physique to
escape the sunlight worth replied
scp-939's hey Brian
his sentence was overtaken by a scream
as one of the blood red creatures caught
worth by the ankle knocking him down and
pulling him back to be devoured Jerry
didn't look back he just kept running
back through the tunnel the sound of
scp-939 calling after him and Kyle and
Carly's voices made it even harder not
to stop and turn even just for a second
but he reminded himself that if he
stopped running then he couldn't lure
the creatures out of the mine and into
the sunlight it wasn't how he'd ever
wanted to go out but maybe that way
Jerry would see his kids again now go
and check out scp-001 can scp-049
finally cure when day breaks and scp-001
when day breaks
scp-682 for more horrifying when
Daybreak scenarios